Here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
Cool.
Hello Johan.
Hi.
Was Christ what's happening?
Yeah.
Good.
I've just,
we'd just say before we went on camera
that I'd met a note to myself that says,
talk slow,
Talk American,
because although I spent
about half the year here,
we British people,
but there's a reorientation where you
suddenly realize I was once in a UN,
I hop in Cactus Arizona and
I was saying to the woman,
right,
like I'll have some pancakes,
whatever it was.
And she kept looking at me going,
what?
I don't have to about
literally three minutes.
She goes,
do you speak English?
I was like,
Ooh,
my people fucking invented it.
Right.
But no one was there to
laugh at my subject because
they didn't understand what
the fuck I was saying.
I,
Arizona is a strange place.
I really love Arizona.
There's great parts.
Like Phoenix is amazing.
Tucson's a great place too,
but it's a wild west sort of a state.
It's one of those weird hold over states
that have a lot of weird old school
laws.
Like,
like,
uh,
I think you could just
walk around with a gun.
Yeah,
you can't.
My main experience in Phoenix
was in Arizona in fact,
was going out with a group of women
who were made to go out on a chain gang
wearing tee shirts saying I was a drug
addict who are members of the public,
mock them in Jira at the
right cause written this book
about where I spoke about
the war on drugs and I went to Joe Arpaio,
sheriff,
our pio,
no longer sheriff now thankfully.
But uh,
yeah,
and it was,
Arizona is a deeply weird place.
It's weird.
A lot of really nice people,
but it's 150,000 degrees.
Yeah.
Well literally,
almost nobody lived there until
I conditioning was invented.
Right.
And you see what I once
met a horrendous mistake,
in fact in Phoenix where I had to walk
somewhere and I could see on the map,
it was like a mile away.
So I was like,
oh,
just walk.
It's fine.
And I get like halfway there and people
are literally stopping that car is
going,
are you okay?
Because the only reason anyone would ever
walk in Phoenix was basically if your
car had broken down in a car to them,
I might have actually just chosen to walk.
Right.
Plus you're so white guy.
I'm like a tomato and used to come out
with a Brazilian who would literally just
look at my body and laugh and be like,
you're so white.
How can a human be so white?
I don't also,
I never have a nice color.
Like I'm either this
albino color or red rock.
I never,
there's no rich brown hue have,
uh,
none of my ancestors,
the Scottish and Swiss.
So they never saw the start.
Right.
And none of my ancestors,
my friend Jamie was over my house
once and he's not this friend Jamie at
different friend Jamie,
who's a British as well.
And my daughter,
who was a,
at the time,
I think she was like 10
or something like that.
She goes,
she goes to my watch,
he goes,
mommy,
he's so white.
She,
and she goes,
yeah.
She goes,
no,
like he's white,
like paper.
So from then on,
Jamie became Jamie White,
like paper.
Very accurate description of
my lack of pigment is curly.
True.
It's funny though,
how much we appreciate
the English accent though.
The English accent is like one of the
best tools for selling things to very
gullible Americans.
Whether it's like people benefit from
constant positive discrimination in the
United States,
right?
It's like having a 10 inch deck,
just having a British accent.
Oh my God,
you got an exit.
All humans have accents.
I've just got,
you know,
let's say a cherished one.
We looked at.
Really,
it makes you feel like
you're more sophisticated.
You're,
you're more well read.
You're more aware of the world.
I mean,
I just am sophisticated
and wild ride anyway.
No,
but you get this constant.
Yeah.
Constantly.
People are ascribing to you much better
qualities then you actually have,
but what does it work in reverse?
Like in,
in England?
What is the reaction to American
accents is it's mostly discussed,
right?
There's a mixture.
Americans,
we grow.
I always think like the relationship
with Britain and America,
it's like I'm one of those police mirrors
because we grow up constantly looking
at the United States,
right?
We're constantly staring through.
We are immersed in American culture,
right?
But when Americans look back at us,
they're just seeing like a
reflection of themselves.
I mean,
Americans watched Downton Abbey and
know about like the queen or whatever,
but there isn't that two way
dialogue that there is that the,
the,
you know,
yeah.
So it's a slightly weird,
so I think we feel very American.
Ryan,
I spent half of the
year here and you know,
every now and then you come up against
these deep cultural differences that it
just like,
oh fuck,
okay.
Right.
This is really not my culture.
Right?
And it's those moments of disorientation
a really strange like gimme one,
if we're going example,
well this is a question
Americans ask all the time,
but I have literally never
heard of European ass,
right?
I asked the question,
what's your story?
Every American,
you can go to the most crusty,
right wing person coming out of Mara
Largo or a kid in West Baltimore and you
can say,
well,
it's your story.
And they'll have an answer.
The only context I can imagine
a British person saying,
what's your story?
Would be in a police interrogation.
It would be an extremely hostile question.
What's your story?
Right?
It would be,
you just wouldn't ever say it,
right?
We don't Americans narrativize their
lives in a way I absolutely love.
And as a journalist,
he writes books about like depression
and addiction and you want people to talk
about their lives.
It's an unbelievable gift t right?
That people will tell you.
So I remember once being on a bus in
Mississippi and sitting next to a woman,
and within five minutes
of chatting to her,
she told me about like
her two miscarriages,
how her mother hated her.
And I thought if we were Swiss,
where my dad's from,
you wouldn't tell me this
until we got married.
And maybe not even that.
Right?
So there's a level of candor and
storytelling among Americans.
It's one of the best things about this,
this,
you know,
fucked up and amazing place,
right?
I just love it.
There's something about,
there's a,
there's a kind of a narrative openness
that's very different about this place
than Europe.
Anywhere in Europe.
Now when you talk to people in England,
you guys don't have the
same level of social,
not social media,
but of reality television.
You have some like big brother,
but you don't have to
the extent that we have
it here,
right?
Yeah,
it hasn't.
Well,
I mean your country has literally
been taken over by reality television,
right?
We have a royalty and president.
Uh,
no,
it hasn't
conquered the whole culture in that way.
Well,
he's a reality television president,
but he's sort of a game
show host president.
Like that's how I used to describe
myself and I was hosting fear factor.
They were like,
you hosted reality show Mike,
sort of.
It's a game show.
It's just a fucked up game show.
It's like,
and Trump was hosting a
game show essentially.
Right?
It was a contest.
It wasn't like keeping
up with the Kardashians.
That's interest.
True reality show.
Because there's literally nothing going
on other than these people's lives and
whatever orchestrated bullshit they
put in to make it more interesting.
Yeah.
I hadn't thought of it that way.
I think that's cool because,
but I think that's part of the
thing that I was getting to about.
Uh,
Americans always wanted to
give you their narrative.
They always want to give
you the story of their life.
So when someone says,
what's your story?
They already have it ready.
You know,
because it's almost like we feel like
we're in some sort of a small television
show all the time or some
sort of small production.
It's like almost a part of our who we are.
Yeah.
Every American
can thinks that the star,
if there were a movie,
right.
And I forget who said this,
but someone realize,
you know,
sometimes in life you realize
you're just the extra,
right?
You're in the corner of the shot.
Right,
right.
And,
um,
yeah,
I think that's true.
And I think that's,
that's not as true of British people,
or I think there's certain,
how to put it like this,
a certain kind of self deprecation.
You're taught as a British person,
you're tall.
And I had to kind of
unlearn it living here.
So what would be examples?
Uh,
I forget where I read this story,
so maybe it's not true,
but I remember in it years ago,
so we had these terrible
subway bombs in 2005,
I'm sure you remember for young British
men go on to the London Underground and
murder,
I think it was over 50
people and two weeks later,
another group of,
um,
jihadis tried to do the same thing,
but they hadn't built the bombs very well.
So they go down into the subway and the,
there's a loud bang,
but it doesn't connect with a detonator.
So there's a loud bang,
but it doesn't actually blow everyone.
Obviously people freak the
fuck out as you can imagine.
Right.
And I forget,
maybe this isn't,
maybe this is a story that someone
told them that wasn't factually true,
but he's,
I think it reveals something.
Bri.
Bri,
something about British currents.
Uh,
so if I remember rightly,
um,
three of the bombers escape escape on
the day in a court like a few hours later
and one of them's caught on at the time,
right.
And someone,
I think it was an off duty fire officer
in the story chases after them for ages,
chasing after the guy for ages while
everyone else is running the fuck away.
And it catches the guy and
he throws him to the ground.
And what he said to him was,
the off duty pharmacist says to
the attempted suicide bomber,
you rude,
rude man.
Right.
And what I love about that is like the
idea of the suicide bombing is just like
bad manners.
It's like it's just impolite,
right?
Or even a better example,
which is true.
It was reported at the time,
definitely was,
um,
during the riots we had in 2011,
uh,
in London,
um,
there was one place,
I forget where it is,
where they broke into a luxury goods
store and they could only make a,
it was very strong window so they could
only make a hole in the corner of the
window and it was caught on the security
cameras that the rioters formed align
to go in and loot the store.
Right.
That's how deep the idea of like Keurig
and make it align is in British culture.
Even in a riot were like,
oh no.
I think you where you were before me.
Right?
I've got a in front Isabelle Bank,
Hey,
he lives in,
he lives in London and she liked me.
If I've ever heard it
be up to she read that.
I'd be like,
you're fucking English.
You did it.
I have a riot this and I'm Roger.
Probably get cure.
What's wrong with you people?
Right?
You guys don't have black Friday sales.
You not with,
they've just started.
Yeah.
It's an unfortunate business.
Might be the end of humility.
Exactly.
We're not going to make it.
We survived.
The Nazis were not fucking
survived in black Friday.
Right.
There's something about those deals when
people get that bargain and then they
opened that door ready go
and people pile through.
All humanity gets tossed aside and get
you in this sign to the fucking financial
desperation of ordinary Americans.
Right?
It's a little bit of that,
but it's also the competitive nature of
those things where you're trying to grab
the few remaining items that are 25%
off and even saving for this TV for six
months.
And there it is right in front of you and
he charge and people are fighting left
and right.
It's awful.
It says it's just a terrible
way for people to interact
with each other.
Oh,
so a,
what are you going to hear from me?
So we were going to talk about,
yeah,
I was wearing,
she told you because we talked last
time about my book about depression loss
conditions and one thing,
it was just as me as
we talk about the book,
I write about addiction and the war on
drugs and really was that out last time
you get a book that came up for you just
come out in a new edition where there's
loads of extra material particular about
the opiate crisis and essentially cause
so you added to it.
Yeah.
Loads of new stuff because the epics
about five years old now and um,
although with loads of new stuff now,
but you know,
it was something I cared about for this
really like personal reason in that one
of my earliest memories is to trying
to wake up one of my relatives and not,
not being able to,
I didn't,
I didn't understand why
then because was little boy.
But as I got older I realized we had
drug addiction in my family and it got to
the point where I was writing,
chasing the scream or
book about the drug war,
about,
I guess I started eight years ago and
some of the people I love when a really
shitty condition,
terrible state,
and I was trying to figure out what to do.
Nothing I was doing was working.
Nothing I was doing was helping.
And I decided,
right,
okay,
well there are lots of people all over
the world are trying to deal with this
problem.
I want to go and meet with them,
talk with them.
So I ended up going on this big journey.
It took three years.
I traveled over 30,000 miles.
I want it to sit with,
you know,
people who'd been through addiction.
It actually led to a lot of other
aspects of the war on drugs.
It doesn't count as important as the,
what we do about addiction.
Um,
I don't want to sit with the places that
had the harshest possible policies like
we mentioned,
Arizona where I went out with these women
were made to go out on chain gangs and
they're humiliated and tormented Vietnam
where they make people with addiction
problems go into literally forced labor
camps and the places that had the most
compassionate possible policies like
Portugal where they all drugs when
incredible results Switzerland
with they legalized heroin.
Incredible results.
Um,
and I guess I ended up
just spending so much time.
It's such a crazy mixture of people from,
uh,
you know,
transgendered crack dealer in Brooklyn
who ended up actually being one of the
smartest people I know to hit man for
the deadliest Mexican drug cartel who's
definitely not one of the
smartest people I know.
And I learned loads of things.
But I guess the heart of what I learned
is just so much of what we've been told
about this for so long.
It's now a hundred years since we
started fighting the war on drugs in this
country and it was then imposed
on the rest of the world.
So much of what we're told is wrong.
Drugs aren't what we think they are.
Addiction isn't what we think is the war
on drugs isn't what we think it is and
the alternatives to the war on
drugs and what we think they are.
So in some ways it's kind of daunting to
Rick go all over the world and realize
so much of what we take
for granted isn't right.
But that opens up this whole
exciting other set of possibilities.
The,
the main reason why people assumed that
people do drugs is to escape reality.
Um,
what do you think is the primary
thing that they're running from?
So you've got to separate out two things.
And this surprised me cause my
family's experience was pretty bad and
catastrophic addiction.
But most druggies,
even the main drug war body in the world,
the UN Office of drug control admits
that 90% of all currently banned drug use
is what they call non problematic.
So the person isn't addicted and
it doesn't damage their health,
right?
So 90% so let's set that aside.
We'll come back to that.
Okay.
That's like 90% that's recreational use
where people use because it makes their
lives better.
Then you've got the 10 Hoffie sip of
wine or or a or c or a whole range of a
whole range of currently cannabis,
a whole range of currently illegal drugs.
Um,
in most cases there are some people
who have addictions to cannabis,
but you said that you don't got,
got to ask,
well,
what's happening with this
10% who have got a problem?
Right?
What's going on?
And one of the things that really blew
my mind in the research we're chasing the
scream was realizing I had deeply
misunderstood what addiction is.
I had misunderstood the thing I thought
I had been seeing in front of me since I
was a kid.
Right?
So most people,
let's think about heroin addiction
because that's close to me.
Most people,
if we stop the next 20
people to walk past your,
you know,
your your studio,
and we said to them,
what causes heroin addiction?
I think they'd look at
us like we were stupid.
And they'd say,
well,
the clue's in the name dip shit,
right?
Heroin causes her.
In addition,
we've been told this
story for a hundred years.
It's become totally part of our,
our common sense,
right?
We think if we took the,
we took the next 20 people after that,
he walked past the studio and we injected
them all with heroin every day for a
month.
At the end of that month,
they'd all be heroin
addicts for simple reason.
There's chemical hooks in heroin that
their bodies would start to desperately
physically need.
Um,
and we think that a lot of people
think that's what addiction is,
right?
It's this physical hunger for the
chemical hook inside the drug,
right?
And there is some reality
to chemical hooks.
They exist.
They're real.
But that's actually a very
small part of what's going on.
The first thing that
alerted me to the fact
there's something wrong with that story
we've been told is when it was explained
to me by loads of doctors in Britain,
where I'm from,
if you step out into the street and you
get hit by a truck and you break your
hip,
you'll be taken to hospital and
you'll be given loads of a drug called
diamorphine.
Diamorphine is heroin,
right?
It's the medical name Vera minutes.
The stuff you'll be given in a hospital
is much better than the shit you buy on
the street because it's medically pure.
It's not contaminated.
And if what we think
about addiction is right,
that it's just caused
by exposure to the drug,
what should be happening to all these
people in British hospitals who have been
given loads of heroin,
right?
Anyone watching this podcast,
he's got a British grandmother who's
had a hip replacement operation.
Your grandmother's taken
a shit ton of heroin,
right?
And if what we think is right,
the addiction is caused primarily
by exposure to the chemical hooks,
lines of these people should believe
in hospital and trying to score on the
streets,
right?
This has been studied very Catholic,
but actually never happens.
Right?
And when I learned that,
it just seems so weird to me.
I thought it couldn't possibly be true,
right?
How could it be?
You've got someone in a hospital bed,
he's taking loads of really potent heroin,
they don't become addicted.
And in the alleyway outside,
you've got someone who's using
actually a weaker form of the drug.
He becomes addicted.
How can,
how can that be?
What's happening here?
And I only began to understand it when I,
when I went to Vancouver,
I met this amazing man could professor
Bruce Alexander who didn't experiment.
That's really transformed how we think
about addiction all over the world.
It's led to a new way of thinking
and loads of new evidence.
So professor Alexander explained to
me this story that we'd been told,
right?
That addiction is caused
by the chemical hooks,
primarily comes from a series
of experiments that were
done earlier in the 20th
century.
They're really simple experiments.
Your viewers can try them at home if
they're feeling a little bit shitty today,
right?
You take a rat,
you put it in a cage,
and you give it two water bottles.
One is just water and the other is water
laced with either heroin or cocaine.
You might remember in the 1980s there's
a famous partnership for drug free
America ad that shows this experiment,
right?
And the rat in this cage starts to drink.
The PF always prefers the heroin water
and almost always kills itself within a
week or two,
right?
So there you go.
That's,
that's our story that
you're exposed to the drug.
It takes you over and then you just die,
right?
But in the 70s professor
Alexander comes along and says,
he was working with people with
addiction problems and he's like,
well,
hang on a minute.
We put these rats alone in an empty cage.
They've got nothing that makes
life meaningful for rats,
right?
What would happen if we
did this differently?
So he built a cage that
he called rat park,
which is basically like having a rat's,
right?
They've got loads of friends,
they've got loads of cheese,
they've got as a colored balls,
they can have loads of sex.
Anything arap finds meaningful
in life is there in rat park.
And they've got both the water bottles,
the normal water and the drug border.
And of course they try both.
They don't know what's in them.
This is the fascinating thing in rat park,
they didn't like the Waterbury much.
None of them ever use it compulsively.
The heroin
was the heroin water.
None of them ever use it compulsively.
None of them have overdose.
So you go from almost a hundred percent
compulsive use and death by overdose
when their lives are shitty to none.
When they have the things
that make life meaningful.
And there's loads of human examples.
I'm sure we'll we'll,
we'll talk about,
but the,
the main thing I took from this is
that the opposite of addiction is not
sobriety.
The opposite of addiction is connection.
We have to ask ourselves what are the
contexts in which people become addicted?
Because there are some contexts where
people buying these drugs extremely
addictive and there are some context
where they don't become addicted at all.
This something,
the drug plays a role.
Chemical x are real.
I can talk about how we know
that they play some role,
but they're actually a surprisingly small
role of what's going small amount of
what's going on.
We know this from,
I mean,
there's so many examples,
but I'll give you,
give me another one in at
the same time as rat park,
there was an experiment going on that
everyone listens to this repair of the
Vietnam war in Vietnam.
Shitloads of American
troops were using heroin,
right?
It was very easy to get it out
there that actually insanely,
they had cracked down on cannabis.
And so people had moved to heroin
because sniffer dogs can't detect,
um,
heroin as easily as cannabis.
See,
calories was everywhere.
Sorry.
Uh,
heroin is everywhere.
Loads of American troops were using it.
And if you look at what
people said at the time,
the authorities,
the Nixon White House,
they were shitting themselves
cause they're like,
they believe this chemical
hooks theory of addiction.
So they're like,
fuck,
when this Warren's,
we can have,
you know,
half a million heroin addicts on
the streets of the United States.
There's a really good
study that followed these,
these men home.
And it found that the vast
majority of them just stopped,
right?
They didn't go into and go to rehab.
Most of them that didn't go
into horrific withdrawal.
Some of them had an
uncomfortable flu like symptoms.
But,
um,
most of them just stop.
Now,
if you believe this old theory
that chemical hooks take you over,
that makes no sense.
But if you understand what
professor Alexander is saying,
all the new evidence about addiction
that I go through and chasing the scream,
it makes it makes perfect sense,
right?
You,
me,
everyone in this area.
If I took any of us and put
us in a horrific pestilential
jungle where we don't
want to be,
and I made you kill a load of people
and potentially die at any moment,
you would find heroin much
more appealing than you do now,
right?
If we want to understand why
people turn to painkillers,
we've got to understand
why they're in pain,
right?
Um,
and,
and the core of addiction,
it's made me,
I learned from these amazing
experts all over the world,
the core of addiction.
It's about not wanting to be present
in your life because your life is too
painful,
a place to be.
And once you understand that,
you can see why what we've
been doing is such a disaster,
right?
Cause the theory we have
with the war on drugs.
Think about Arizona.
We can talk about that more,
but I,
you know,
like I say,
I went to this nightmare
prison it Estrella prison in,
in Phoenix,
Arizona,
where people are humiliated.
And the theory behind that,
part of the theory behind the war on
drugs is if you've got people who are
addicted,
you got to inflict pain on them to,
you know,
give them an incentive to stop,
right?
But once you understand that pain is in
fact the fuel of addiction is in fact
the primary cause of addiction.
You can see why sometimes
people say that doesn't work.
Truth is much worse,
right?
That makes addiction worse.
Those women I went out with and
spent all that time with who are,
you know,
humiliate.
I remember in that prison we come back
from being on the chain gang where they
have to,
sometimes they have to dig graves.
They weren't doing that
the day I was there.
They had to collect garbage the day
I was one of the days I was there.
But we come back and normally
with prisons as a journalist,
they don't want to show you anything,
right?
You're like,
you have to kind of really finagle to
get them to show you anything in this
prison.
Um,
it's like a pantomime of cruelty.
They want to show it to you.
The whole point is to
humiliate these people,
right?
So the women I've been talking to him,
the men were really terrified of what
they called the whole right is the
solitary blog.
And so I said to the gods,
will you show me the whole,
I was sure they sent it.
They're like,
yeah,
sure.
Come on.
Show.
Yeah.
So go around to the whole,
and these women who benefit the
most like trivial infractions,
like having a cigarette
is literally a hole,
right?
It's like a concrete block.
You're on your own.
There's nothing in it.
There's a tiny window
where you can see sunlight,
no TV,
nothing.
Um,
I remember speaking to a woman who
was in this and suddenly thinking,
this is the closest you could get to an
exact human recreation of the cages that
guaranteed addiction in rats.
Right?
And this is what we're doing,
thinking it will stop
these women being addicted.
It's the system we've built.
A doctor Gabble Martay and
amazing guy said to me,
you know,
if negative consequences
stopped addiction,
there won't be a single
addict in the world.
Right?
What have people with addiction
problems not suffered?
Humiliation have they not endured.
So we've got this,
we've got to really shift our
perspective on what addiction is.
And there are places that have done this
that have led to incredible results.
The,
uh,
I love that rat experiment one,
because that had always been parroted
as this is the proof positive that the,
these drugs are so terrible for you.
But once they figured out that if
you take those rats and put them in a
wonderful place and they
don't have addiction,
it really does make you step back and go,
okay,
what is exactly going on here?
Obviously there's chemical hooks.
They are real,
like people that are on sustained
prolonged use of opiates,
especially,
uh,
people with back injuries have an
incredibly difficult time kicking them,
even really positive people who
don't necessarily have awful lives.
But,
um,
uh,
it's,
it's one of those things that gets in
your head and then you sort of paired it.
You,
you've,
you've heard it,
you repeat it.
But it's the reason why
I asked you the question.
It's like,
what?
What is,
what is the cause for most
people you believe it's,
uh,
an unfulfilled life or a painful life or
painful self image or remorse for your
past?
Or what is it that,
do we have like primary reasons or primary
attributes that we attached to these
people that are drug addicted?
Yeah,
so this was what my more recent book,
which is called lost connections,
uncovering the real causes of depression
in the unexpected solutions is,
is about,
cause I think the core of addiction is
it's about trying to deal with pain,
right?
But the causes of human pain,
obviously huge.
But what I learned is the scientific
evidence for nine causes of kind of deep
despair.
Right now if you think about
depression and very similar factors,
plot with addiction,
they're actually densely interconnected,
um,
phenomena.
But there are real biological factors,
right?
Your genes can make you
more vulnerable to that.
Just like some people find it
easier to put on weight than others.
And there are real brain changes that
happen when you become depressed or
addicted.
That can make it harder to get out,
right?
But at most of the factors
that are causing this,
despair are not factors in our biology
that factors in the way we live.
I think it's a kind of,
this doesn't cover all of the causes
that I learned about Veloce connections,
but it causes a lot of them.
Everyone watching your show knows
they have natural physical needs,
obviously,
right?
You need food,
you need water,
you need shelter,
you need cleaner.
Exactly.
If I took those things away from you,
you'd be fucked really quickly.
Right?
But there's equally strong evidence.
The all human beings have
natural psychological needs,
right?
You need to feel you belong.
You need to feel your life
has meaning and purpose.
You need to feel that people
see you and value you.
You need to be,
you've got a future that makes sense.
And this culture we've built is good at
lots of things and I'm really glad to be
alive today for all sorts of reasons.
Had to go to the dentist the other day.
I'm glad to be alive now and
not like a hundred years ago,
but there's a lot evidence that we'd been
getting less and less good at meeting
these deep underlying psychological needs.
Let's think about you
referred to the opioid crisis,
for example,
because I think even a lot of really good
people are profoundly misunderstanding
what's happening with the opioid crisis.
Where is the opioid crisis happening,
right?
Been to a lot of the epicenters a bit
places like Monadnock in New Hampshire.
Why is,
why are things so disastrous there?
Why is there much higher,
uh,
opioid addiction in West Virginia
than on the Faculty of Harvard?
Right?
People in the Faculty of Harvard
have much better access to opioids,
right?
Everyone there has good health insurance.
They have much better access.
What's going on that
some amazing economists,
Angus Deaton and Ann Case,
did a massive study of this and they said
that we need to understand the opioid
deaths mainly as what they
call deaths of despair,
right?
It's not a coincidence that the places
were opioid addiction is highest,
are also the places where suicide
not with opioids is highest.
We're antidepressant
prescriptions or highest,
there's a whole,
these things are clustering
together for a reason,
right?
And you don't have to spend much time
in those places to see people through no
fault of their own.
Have I liked the rats in that first cage,
right?
They had been deprived of the
things that make life meaningful.
It doesn't mean chemical
hooks don't play some role.
They do play a role.
But I've been to the places that have
solved this and it wasn't by thinking
primarily about that.
So just talk about the reality.
Chemical Hooks it.
That's right.
Cause it's very important to
understand in relation to opioids.
This is a very strong agreement among
scientists that the most powerful chemical
hook we know is nicotine,
right?
You smoke cigarettes.
Like my mother smokes
seventies cigarettes a day.
He smoked cigarettes.
The thing you feel a physical
craving for when you stop,
which my mother would never do,
is,
um,
is nicotine.
Right?
That's the chemical hook.
Um,
and so in the late eighties,
when nicotine patches were invented,
there's this huge wave of
optimism among scientists get,
they're like,
oh,
right,
cigarette smoking is an addiction
to the chemical hook nicotine.
Now we can give people all the chemical
hook they're addicted to without any of
this shitty cancer causing smoke,
people are going to start smoking,
right?
Um,
so nicotine patches are introduced in
the US surgeon general's report a couple
of days later,
fines,
highly motivated people
using nicotine patches.
Um,
17% of them will stop smoking,
right?
That's important to say.
That is not nothing,
right?
That means if you meet the Chemical
Hook for people who are addicted to
cigarettes,
17% of them will stop entirely.
That's a big deal,
right?
That's saved a huge
number of people's lives.
But obviously 17% is not
100% that leaves 83%.
The gotta be explained
by the other things.
And that's really the factors
that I talked about in,
in Los Connections.
So,
I mean,
there's a whole range of them,
but you know,
if you are acutely lonely,
we are the loneliest
society there's ever been,
right?
You are much more likely to
be vulnerable to despair,
depression,
addiction.
If you are controlled
and humiliated at work,
which most people now are to some degree,
you're much more
vulnerable to these things.
There's a whole range of
go through nine of these,
these factors in the book.
But to me the most important thing and
thinking about the opioid crisis and um,
I find it really frustrating that this
is never discussed in the American debate
is I've been to the place that solves
an opioid crisis that had a disastrous
opioid crisis and ended it.
Right?
And they did something that's
very different to Americans
are being urged to do.
So I'm a Swiss citizen
because my dad's from there.
So I switched to them.
Well,
and by the time you get to the year 2000,
Switzerland is having
like an opioid nightmare,
right?
Um,
people can look up videos from the time,
but you know,
people like Swiss people are obsessed
with order is not coincidence.
They invented clocks and all that shit,
right?
Like in their public parks,
people like injecting in the
neck like nightmare scenes,
right?
That'd be bad anywhere.
But to Swiss people,
this is like the worst nightmare,
right?
And they try all sorts of things.
They tried the American way,
arresting people,
punishing people,
shaming people,
and it just keeps getting worse and worse.
And then one day they get this,
this incredible woman called Ruth Dreifuss
who I got to know later who becomes a
minister of health and then the president,
the first ever female
president of Switzerland,
um,
she explains to people,
I think the solution
is to legalize heroin.
And she said,
I know that sounds really shocking cause
when you hear the word legalization,
what you picture is anarchy and chaos.
She said,
what we have now is anarchy and chaos,
right?
We have unknown criminals selling
unknown chemicals to unknown drug users.
All in the dark,
all filled with violence,
disease and chaos legalization.
She explained is the way we
restore order to this madness.
Right?
So the way it works isn't spent
lot of time in these places.
And obviously no,
or maybe there's some really
hardcore libertarians,
but almost no one believes
we should legalize heroin
the way alcohol or cannabis
illegal.
Right?
No one thinks there should
be a heroine island CBS.
That's not the plan.
Right.
What did in Switzerland is
if you had a heroin problem,
you were assigned to a clinic.
I went,
spent a lot time in the one in Geneva,
the former president,
Ruth dreifuss lives opposite this clinic.
I think that tells you something.
Um,
like across the street,
across the street,
what,
what it,
what it does,
it's the way it works
is she should move well,
but if you see the clinic that day,
why?
Right?
So the way it works is you have to go
to the clinic at seven o'clock in the
morning because Swiss people believe
in doing things really fucking early.
It's constant disagreement
between me and my dad.
You turn up,
you go in,
they give you your hair in there,
they give you medically pure heroin.
You can't take it out with yet.
You've got to use it there.
Partly because I don't
want you to sell it on.
But mainly because they want to monitor
you to make sure you know you don't
overdose.
Um,
you use it there and then you leave to
go to your job because you're given a
load to support,
to get housing work and
therapy to the grout.
Why you can't bear to
be present in your life.
Right?
So it's really important
they give two things.
That's puts,
bear in mind these two things because
the opposite of what we're doing at the
moment here,
give them the safest possible version
of the drug and give the massive amounts
of help to deal with the
reasons why they need that drug.
Now they're giving them a drug
or the injecting it in them.
Yeah,
they know they,
the individual injects himself or herself.
So if you,
if you were the patient,
I'm the nurse,
I give you the heroin and
I give you a clean syringe.
And one of the things
that really surprised me,
I at first I found really weird is they
will give you any dose of heroin that
you want apart from one
that would kill you.
And there is never any
pressure to cut back.
And yeah,
I went there when it was 13 years after
this at first started and there was
almost nobody on the program.
Um,
from the start there were like three
people who've been there the whole time.
Almost everyone does cut
back and stop over time.
And I remember saying to a Rita mango,
who's the chief psychiatrist there,
well,
well how can that be?
Cause we're told the
chemical hooks take you over.
You need more and more.
If you had an unlimited supply,
you would just carry on forever.
What?
How can,
how can,
how do you explain this?
And she looked at me like
I was dumb and she said,
well,
we help them and their lives get better.
And as your life gets better,
you don't want to be anesthetized so much.
Which ones that's explained
to you is so obvious.
Right?
But it's worth just explaining the results
of the Swiss program in the Phillies
15 years now,
in the 15 years since this began,
according to the best scientific evidence
be like Professor Ambrose Oxton Haagen
have shown that had been zero deaths,
overdose deaths on legal heroin.
Not One person.
There's been a massive fall in overdose
deaths outside the legal program cause
people transfer in because why would you
carry on using expensive shitty street
drugs when you could be getting,
you know,
help and given the drug for free.
Um,
and once it is fascinating about this
is Swiss people are really conservative,
right?
My Swiss relatives make
Donald Trump look like Oprah.
And yet Swiss people after
this had been in practice for,
uh,
five years,
had a referendum on
whether to get rid of it.
And 70% of Swiss people
voted to keep heroin legal.
Not Cause they're so compassionate.
To be honest.
That's not,
they're not,
they're really not.
Uh,
it was cause crime fell so much.
Right?
It's much cheaper to give some crime fall.
I've got the statistics in the book.
It's fear since I wrote it,
but there was,
I think something like a 50% fall in
street street crime street prostitution
literally ended,
right?
There was no street
prostitution after that.
It turns out women don't want to be
on the street being fucked by random
strangers.
But the body,
if they've got like an alternative,
who knew?
But the um,
so it was an enormous fallen crime
across the board and the police confirmed
that everyone agrees with
that in Switzerland and all
the kind of anarchy in the
streets just just stopped.
Right.
But,
but what the reason I think it is really
relevant to the opioid crisis is what
we're doing is the exact opposite,
right?
So they give them the
safe version of the drug,
give them help to figure out why practical
support to change their environment
to get out of the isolet occasion more
into a life that's more like rat park.
What do we do if your doctor in this
country finds out that you are using say
Percocet or Oxy,
not because you've got back pain,
but because you've got an addiction,
your doctor by law has to cut you off,
right?
They don't,
they can be busted as a dealer.
It's happened to lots of doctors
so they have to cut you off.
So instead of giving you the drug,
we stopped you getting the drug.
Most people then,
or not most of very large number then
transfer to much more dangerous street
drugs like heroin.
Secondly far from giving you
how to turn your life around.
We give you a criminal record,
we shame you,
we stigmatize you.
We put barriers between
you and reconnecting.
The opposite of addiction is connection.
But what do we do?
We put barriers between
people and reconnecting.
This is why that's one part of it,
right?
So there's the drug policy part of it,
uh,
where we are doing exactly the opposite
of the country that succeeded in ending
it's opiod epidemic.
But there's something,
I think there's even deeper than that,
which you really see in
places like West Virginia,
Monadnock,
the kind of hearts of the,
the opioid crisis,
which is we're also creating a society
that is becoming harder and harder for
people to be present in,
especially in those,
in those places.
There's an analogy I
keep thinking of in the,
in the 18th century in Britain,
loads of people were driven out of the
countryside into these disgusting urban
slums in like a London and Manchester.
And,
and something happened that
that has been well documented.
There was then called the gin craze,
right?
Where basically shitloads of people
just became alcoholics drank again until
they,
right.
There's a famous
painting from the time called Gin Lane
of a mother down in like a bottle of
vodka while a baby like
falls out the window.
Right.
And things like that
really were happening.
If you look at what
people said at the time,
very similar to what they're saying now,
they said,
look at this evil drug gin.
Look what it's fucking done to us.
If only we could get rid
of this evil drug gin,
there's problem will go away.
Right.
We know now when we look
back at the gin craze,
it can have been Jenn that caused it
because anyone in Britain who's over the
age of 18 can go and buy gin.
Right.
And while we still have some alcoholics
to be sure we don't have mass epidemics
of alcoholism,
you don't have babies
falling out of windows.
What changed wasn't the
amount of availability,
it wasn't the availability of the drug.
The drug is more available
now than it was then.
What changed was the amount of
pain and distress in the society,
right?
We don't have it started brought
as profoundly disorientated.
I mean it's going up because
we're creating more orientation.
So we,
if you create a society where peoples
basic psychological needs are not met
right,
where they have shrinking
number of friends and social
connections where they're
taught that life is about money and buying
shit and displaying it on Instagram,
excuse me,
where they spend most
of their time at jobs,
they find unfulfilling,
controlling and humiliating.
You can,
uh,
create growing pools of people who can't.
And you,
by the way,
if you're constantly insecure,
financially insecure,
half of all Americans have
through no fault of their own,
have been able to set aside $500
for if an emergency comes along,
she cretins pervasive
insecurity in the society.
You're going to create very large numbers
of people who are going to want to an
fill Anita anesthetize themselves.
Now,
that's not a good solution.
Obviously I don't think heroin opioids,
these are not good
solutions to these problems,
but,
but it's not a crazy solution either.
There's a line I think of all the time.
I don't quite see it very often because
people can really react against this
insight.
I think it's actually important.
You know,
Marianne Faithfull,
the great like sixties British singer,
she went out with Mick Jagger and
normally that's why people remember.
She's much better than Mick Jagger.
Um,
in her memoir,
she shot heroin addiction in the 60.
She was homeless for awhile.
She has this very challenging line,
I think about a lot,
I'm going to phrase it slightly wrong,
but she said,
um,
heroin saved my life because
if it wasn't for heroin,
I would have killed myself at that point.
Right?
Now Marianne Faithfull,
if not saying heroin was a
good solution to homelessness,
but we've got to understand this drug
use is happening because it performs a
function,
right?
One of the most important things,
I don't know for both of my books,
for chasing the scream
and lost connection,
is that these forms of despair,
depression,
anxiety,
addiction,
they are meaningful signals,
right?
They are telling us something.
The fact that there had been
rising year after year after year,
that we're now at the point where average
white male life expectancy has fallen
in this country for the first time in
the entire piece time history of the
United States.
That is a signal that is telling us
something and that's because of drug
addiction and overwhelming cause
of drug addiction and suicide.
It's,
it's risen to that point.
Are there other factors
going on like obesity,
but that the main drivers are,
um,
oh,
overdose and suicide and that he's telling
us something of what we've been doing
up to now is we've been
insulting that signal.
We've either been saying depressed people,
addicted people are just weak.
Or we've been saying,
oh,
it's just a problem in their brain that
there are real things going on in their
brains,
of course.
Um,
or we've been saying,
you know,
it's just craziness.
Um,
but in fact,
it is largely a response
to the way we're living.
Of course,
there are other things going on as well,
and we can talk about them.
And once you understand that,
you realize there's got
to be a deeper response.
And I went to places that had done it,
not just Switzerland,
Switzerland.
What is the lower the overall population?
Five and a half million.
So it's a small
comparatively small country.
Yeah.
Um,
how much money do they have to
spend to keep this program going?
And what are the,
what is it a time constraint in
terms of like how long has a,
a person who's got an addiction
problem allowed to stay there and,
and receive treatment?
There's no time constraint.
You can stay on for your
entire life if you want to.
In practice that doesn't happen very,
they stay in the facility?
No,
no.
They live in apartments.
They just visit.
They just go every day
or whenever they want to.
I mean,
I think you can go twice
a day and it's free.
It's free.
It doesn't cost anything.
I mean some people,
once they have jobs,
then pay health insurance and
health insurance pays for it.
But if you don't have
money then they pay for it.
And,
and one thing that was
fascinating is they found it.
It wasn't,
um,
Joanne set,
uh,
did good research on or science
good research on this for,
she did research.
The Open Society Foundation.
It's actually cheaper than the
police constantly harassing people,
putting them in prison,
putting them on trial.
Those are really expensive things to do.
Heroin is unbelievably cheap.
If you buy it legally,
right?
They did the amount of money they
would save just in street crime being
radically reduced.
Exactly.
It makes,
it makes the life of the
person with addiction better.
It makes the lives of ordinary of other
citizens who are not addicted better.
Um,
and it saves money.
Right.
Which is why stress people
who are very pragmatic,
they're not,
you know,
the most compassionate people,
but they are very pragmatic people.
That's why it was so popular system.
Let's think about another place that
adopted really different drug policies.
Right?
Um,
cause I think it's something we
can learn from there as well.
So Portugal,
around the time Switzerland's
having it's horrific heroin crisis,
Portugal is having a fucking nightmare,
right?
By the year 2001% of the
population was addicted to heroin,
which is incredible,
right?
And every year they were like Switzerland.
They were trying the American way,
shame,
punishment,
stigma and things just kept
getting worse and worse and worse.
And then one day the prime minister
and the leader of the opposition got
together and the lawyer,
we can't go on like this.
What are we going to,
what are we going to do?
And they decided to do
something really radical,
something no one had done since the
drug war began in this country 70 years
before.
They said,
should we like ask them scientists
what the best thing to do would be?
So they set up a panel of scientists
and doctors led by an amazing man.
I got to know in Portugal,
Dr Wow.
Killough it totally extraordinary person.
Um,
and uh,
he'd run the first of a drug
treatment center in Portugal,
founded after the dictatorship
and they said to them,
you guys just go away,
look all the evidence and figure
out what the hell we can do.
So they go away for two years.
They,
they learn about rat park,
they learn loads of things and
they come back and they say,
okay,
solution is we want to decriminalize
all drugs from cannabis to crack.
But,
and this is the crucial next step.
Take all the money we currently
spend all fucking people up,
arresting them,
shaming them,
and presenting them and spend all that
money instead on turning their lives
around.
And interestingly,
it's not really what we think of as drug
treatment here in the United States,
right?
So they do some residential
rehab that has some value.
Main thing they did was a big program of
job creation for people with addiction
problems saying you used to be a mechanic,
they go to a garage and they said,
if you employ this guy for a year,
we'll pay half his wages again,
much cheaper than sending him to prison.
Right.
Uh,
they set up a big program of small loans.
So people with addiction problems
could set up and run businesses.
The things that they thought
were important at the time.
People like this is crazy.
They're just gonna spend it all on drugs.
Lunacy.
Right?
And by the time I went to Portugal,
it was again a 13 years
since this has gone.
And the results were him.
Addiction was down by 50%.
This is by far the biggest from
the British journal of Criminology.
The best scientific study of this.
Um,
overdose deaths were massively down.
HIV was massively down.
Every single indicator on problems related
to drug use had fallen like a cliff.
Right?
It wasn't perfect.
They still got problems of course,
but there was a massive improvement.
And one of the reasons you know it works
so well is that virtually no one in
Portugal wants to go back.
I went and interviewed a great
guy called [inaudible] Guerra,
who at the time of the decriminalization
was the top drug cop in the whole
country.
And he said,
what I'm sure those of your listeners
are thinking right at the time,
which was like,
if we decriminalize all drugs,
we can have an explosion in drug use.
We can have lots of kids.
He's interesting nightmare.
We can't do this.
And when I went to see him,
uh,
the audios on the Chasen screen website,
he said a saying like
everything I said would happen,
didn't happen,
and everything the other
side said would happen,
did.
And he talks about how he felt really
ashamed that it's been so many years prior
to the decriminalization screwing
people's lives up when it could have been
helping them turn their lives around.
And,
and this is something that
I saw all over the world,
right?
The places that have drug policies based
on shame and stigma and the fantasy
that you can get rid of drug use,
which you can never do.
Um,
they have mass really
terrible and rising problems.
The places that have policies based on,
okay,
let's restore order to the market and
let's give love liberty to drug users and
love and compassion and practical
help for people with addiction.
Problems have declining drug problems,
right?
Again,
not perfect,
but it was such a significant
improvement that support in Portugal.
I mean,
they've got five main political parties
and none of them want to go back,
right?
That tells you something right now.
When they did this in Switzerland,
what was the primary cause for this drug
addiction and how did they deal with
that?
So if they dealt with it in
Portugal with these loans and,
and,
and helping our businesses by paying
for half the salary and all those things
like that seemed like wonderful ideas.
What do they do in Switzerland to
sort of mitigate what are the issues,
whatever the issues were that were
causing people to be drug addicts in the
first place.
So it's a combination.
They gave people lots of therapy.
So I remember one of the people I spent
some time within that clinic had been,
um,
terribly sexually abused.
There's a lot of evidence that giving
survivors of sexual abuse safe places in
which they can release their shame about
that leads to a big fall in depression,
addiction and other problems.
There's a lot of evidence that,
that,
that kind of abuse is,
is a big driver of a lot of addiction
for a lot of people that clearly not
everyone.
Um,
some of it was just,
there were people who had never been
given a chance in life or I hadn't never
had stable lives.
Uh,
it was kind of a mixture of things.
And one of the things that's really good
about this three system is it wasn't
saying in this kind of cookie cutter way,
the up and half often happens in drug
treatment in the United States are there,
there's plenty of good examples as well.
You know,
you don't arrive and they say,
this is your problem.
We're here to tell you your problem
and how to solve your problem.
It's very much guided by
actually the person themselves,
right?
People who are in deep pain.
The,
the,
the core of it is you
have to listen to them,
right?
If we think about this addiction,
depression in the way that I'm arguing
that we should see them as signals that
are telling us something.
Most important thing is
to listen to the signal,
right?
I remember saying,
I thought about a lot this
weird experience that I
kept thinking about all the
time.
I was writing my book,
lost connections about depression and
started quite late and late in the day
that I realized why I kept
thinking about it so much.
I was in Vietnam about five years ago now,
maybe a little bit less.
Um,
and I did this really stupid thing.
I was,
I was in Hanoi and I was really tired.
I was doing research for different
book that I haven't finished yet.
And uh,
by the side of the road I saw this big
red apple women selling it and I'm sure
haggling.
And so I paid like $5 for
this apple or something and I,
and I took it back to my hotel.
I was so tired.
I lay on the bed and I start
eating it and it was just gross.
Right?
There was some really,
it's chemical taste.
It was like how I imagined a food would
taste after a nuclear war when I used to
watch these films in the 80s.
Right.
Um,
but I was so tired,
even though I knew it was wrong,
I ate like half of it and threw it in
the garbage and the next like four days I
was just like violently sick right there.
Like just in like something
from the exit strategy.
So I'm lying there in front of CNN and
occasionally projectile vomiting and it
gets like I'd had food poisoning before.
I basically lived on fried chicken in
my twenties I was not new to this Rodeo
and after about four days,
I said to Hawaiian,
my fixer and translator who was a ranger,
I was there to interview
survivors of the war,
the Vietnam War for something.
I'm like,
look,
I'm only here for another
three days or whatever it was.
I've got to go and meet these people.
Otherwise this whole trip would
have been a waste of time.
So he drives me like six or seven hours
into the countryside and we get there
and he's lined up these people
for me to interview and I'm like,
I don't think,
oh,
I don't feel so bad.
Actually,
I was sitting in this hot word,
this,
this woman who was an 86 year old woman
who was the only person from her village
that survived the Vietnam War.
So I'm talking to her and actually
speaking that the room starts to,
I've never had this feeling before and
I've had a thing when you were drunk,
when you fill the rooms,
move it,
it literally felt like the
room was moving around me.
Like,
like I didn't feel like
I was disorientated.
And then while she's talking,
I just like explode all over
her heart from both ads,
like fucking horror show.
Right?
And so I say to her,
I'm just,
just take me back,
put me in the car,
take me back to Hanoi.
Right?
And he's this old woman's like
saying sang to him and I'm just like,
line there.
And he says,
she says,
you've got to go to the hospital.
You were really sick.
And I'm like,
no,
I just need to go back to the I talk.
And he said,
yeah,
and this is the only woman who survived
the Vietnam War in this village.
I'm going to listen to her
health advice over yours.
We're going to the hospital.
So we go to this hospital were,
I'm pretty sure I was
there in the European,
it had been treated.
They take me in and crimes
like completely lying,
going like this is an important WESCO.
It will disgrace Vietnam if he dies there.
Right?
And so I'm lying there and they're like
jabbing me with everything and I'm like,
what's going on?
And they're asking me lots of questions
and I felt the most nauseas I've ever
felt right.
And I kept saying to them,
give me something for the nausea,
three Hawaiian,
because they didn't speak in English.
And the doctor said to me,
you need your nausea.
It will tell us what's
wrong with you right now.
Even lying there and thinking,
it was kind of interesting.
I was where we think of line there and
thinking they figured out what the apple,
and I'm having such a ridiculous
thought where I thought,
I come about to die,
right?
I've been killed by an apple.
I'm like,
eve or like snow white
or like Alan Turing.
And then I was like,
you're about to die in your last thought
is that you're basically a pretentious
con.
I was like horrified by myself.
Anyway,
they gave me this treatment and a few
days later when I leave and I'm talking to
the doctor and I
was discussing various things
with him and I said to him,
what would have happened if I'd,
um,
if I had gone back to Hannah,
if it drove me back to Hanoi and he said,
Oh,
well what happened is my kidneys has
stopped working because I hadn't kept any
water in for four days.
So it was like I had been in the desert
for four days and the doctor said,
all you would have died
on the journey you went,
it made it.
And so can thinking about this experience,
which weirdly it didn't
actually affect my like,
well viewer and a thing.
It's the closest I've ever had
to a near death experience.
But all three,
researching my book about depression,
loss connections,
I kept thinking about this thing,
right?
You need your nausea,
it will tell us what's wrong with you.
And I realized all the time
I had been depressed for,
I think about my relatives and people
I love who'd had addiction problems.
I had seen that my depression,
their addiction as a bit like that.
Nausea,
right?
As like a kind of malfunction,
Saying that you should get rid of and
actually what we need to do is hear it
right?
Because it will tell us
what's wrong with us.
Right?
It doesn't mean it's a good feeling.
It's awful.
Right?
Depression is worse than I've ever felt
a addiction's a terrible state to being.
It's not saying just in some kind of,
you know,
oh,
we need to put up with it.
It's that if we hear the signal,
we can begin to find solutions
and all the places I went,
the places that have solved depression,
crises that I went to,
floss connections,
places that have solved addiction crises,
that w that I went to for chasing
the screen are places that have said,
actually this means something.
Right?
Your pain makes sense.
You feel these ways for reasons
and we need to get down into these,
these deeper reasons,
which is really not what we've done in
the United States is the drug war began,
you know,
a century ago.
So did they figure out in Switzerland
what was causing this rash of addiction?
And just by treating it seems like if
there is some underlying condition that's
causing this depression that's
leading people to drug addiction,
that just giving them free heroin
is not going to fix the root cause.
So how did they find out what the
root cause was and why it was such an
epidemic?
You're totally right that so the hero,
the heroine is does two things.
So partly as you become addicted,
you spiraling the people who
don't have huge private resources.
Some people do,
right?
As you become addicted,
what happens to a lot of people is
you spiral into chaotic street use,
right?
So for a lot of women,
that means sex work.
For a lot of men,
that means property crime.
Some insects work as well,
but mostly not.
And so what happens is actually you,
you become,
you know,
you develop an addiction to,
cause you're dealing with this pain,
but then you actually move into
a much more chaotic way living,
right?
Which,
which causes deeper pain and deeper paid.
Obviously if you're being fucked by
strangers every day and you're treating me
badly,
you're going to want to be even
more anesthetized after that.
Right.
Or if you're frightened that
the police all the time.
So what happens is partly what happened
in Switzerland was giving people the
legal heroin ended the
chaos of street use,
which in itself was
making addiction worse.
That's clearly not the cause cause
you don't start out with the street.
So it was partly that I think it was
partly attending to people's deeper
distress and it's not like there's
one cookie cutter thing that was,
that was the answer.
It was listening to different people
at different stages and looking at,
they'd had some problems
with unemployment,
but you don't want to
overstate that they'd have
some problems with child abuse.
You don't want to overstate that.
It was more like a kind of menu of things.
And most sophisticated
menu of things that,
but,
but the thing that they definitely showed
in the Swiss model and in Portugal and
in lots of other places I went
to is compassionate treatment,
reduces addiction,
right?
And treatment understood in the broadest
sense because it reduces the pain.
The individual is in anything
that reduces the shame.
Stigma and humiliation will over time
reduce addiction for most people,
not everyone.
Some people are in such internal agony,
they will always need anesthetics.
And this I think is a really important
point and one that can be quite
challenging to some people that can,
people like me who have people
they love with addiction problems.
So where are open chasing the scream is
with this story that I think a lot of
people,
um,
think what the fuck is a book about
the war on drugs starting like this.
And I think it tells you so much.
Um,
so in 1939 in a hotel,
midtown Manhattan,
Billie holiday,
the great jazz singer walked on stage.
She sang for the first time a song that
I'm sure all your listeners and viewers
have heard a song called strange fruit,
writes a song against lynching.
It's the idea that,
uh,
in the south,
the bodies of African American men hang
from the trees and they're like a kind
of strange fruit in the south,
right?
This is unbelievably challenging.
At that time,
there are very few
popular songs like that.
Um,
and,
and to have an African American
woman doing it was quite shocking,
right?
She wasn't even allowed to walk
through the front door of the hotel.
They made her go through the service
elevator because she was African American.
And that night Billy holiday gets a
warning from a man called Harry Anslinger
from the agents of a man called
Harry Anslinger that basically says,
stop singing this song and you think,
wait,
what's this got to do
with the war on drugs?
So Harry Anslinger is a man.
Uh,
it was government bureaucrat,
I think the most influential
person no one's ever heard of.
He's affected the lives of the loads
of people listening to your show.
So Harry Anslinger is a
government bureaucrat who
takes over the Department of
prohibition just as alcohol
prohibition is ending.
See,
you've had this big war on alcohol.
It's been a shit show.
It's been a disaster.
And he takes it over and he wants to
keep his government department going.
And he invents the modern war on drugs,
is the first person to ever
use the phrase war on drugs.
And,
and he really builds this war on drugs
around two intense hatred he has.
And Billie holiday's,
the personification of both.
One was a really intense
hatred of African Americans.
I mean,
he was regarded as a
crazy racist in the 1920s,
which gives you a sense
of how racist he was.
He used the n word so
often in official memos.
His own senator said is,
you'd have to resign.
That's how hardcore he was.
Right.
And you also had an intense hatred of
people with addiction problems and Billie
holiday.
And she'd grown up on
the streets of Baltimore,
a part of Baltimore called pig town.
She,
when she was 10,
she was horrific.
She was raped.
Uh,
the man who raped her was sent
to prison for a year and a half.
She was sent a reformatory
for longer than he got right.
She,
she was tormented by the nuns there.
They,
they said he was disobedient.
She brought it on herself.
They used to lock her in a dead bodies
overnight to teach her a lesson.
She eventually ran away.
She tried to find her mother.
Her mother had gone to what's now
called about Roosevelt island.
Now it wasn't called that then when
she was working as a prostitute.
And Billie holiday starts kind of working
in inverted commas next to her mother
in this brotha from when she's like 14.
So she's being raped by men for
money night after night after night.
She's,
you know,
and when they,
the police rescue,
rescue break into the brothel,
they arrest her right
instead of to prison.
Um,
so Billie holiday's trying to numb the
grief and pain that comes from that.
Right?
So she starts out using loads of alcohol
and then she's using loads of other
stuff as well,
mostly heroin.
And when she gets this warning
from Harry Anslinger saying,
stop singing this song,
Billie holiday's attitude is fuck you.
I'm an American citizen.
I was,
what?
I fucking please.
Right.
And at that point,
Harry Anslinger resolves to destroy her.
The first man he sent to to track her
is a man called follow her round is guy
called Jimmy Fletcher.
Harry Anslinger hated
employing a white people,
sorry,
hate to employ African Americans,
but you couldn't really send
a white person into Harlem
to follow Billie holiday
where it be kind of obvious.
Say employed.
This African American guy
called Jimmy Fletcher,
he just quit.
His job title was a bag man.
So he was given the job,
follow Billie holiday.
Everywhere she goes,
befriend her document,
her druggies,
right?
He dances with her in nightclubs.
He gets to know her really well.
And Billie holiday was so amazing that
Jimmy Fletcher fell in love with her and
his whole life he felt really
ashamed of what he did.
He busts.
Uh,
uh,
when they come into searcher Shi,
she,
Shi,
uh,
makes him,
she pisses in front of him and says,
you can look in my purse here.
You can see I don't have anything here.
Um,
she's put on trial at the trial was
called the United States versus Billie
holiday.
And she said that's how it fucking felt.
She sent to prison for 18 months.
She doesn't say a word in prison,
but what happened to her next I think
is the cruelest thing she gets out of
prison.
Um,
and at that time to sing anywhere
where they served alcohol,
you needed what was called a
cabaret performer's license.
Anslinger make sure she doesn't get it.
So one of her friends,
you'll end up a van,
is also great jazz singer said to me,
what's the cruelest thing you can do to
a person is to take away the thing they
love,
right?
They take away singing
from Billie holiday.
So what we do to people with addiction
problems all over the United States,
right?
We give them criminal records that make
it much harder to do the things that are
meaningful to them by work.
For example.
Um,
so in that situation,
obviously Billie holiday relapses,
right?
She starts using a shit ton of heroin.
Again,
a one day in the early 50.
[inaudible] she collapses not far from
where she first song strange fruit.
Um,
the first hospital won't even take her
cause the cause she's got an addiction
problem.
They said we're not having
a second hospital takes her,
but she says to her friend,
Maili dusty on the way in the
Anslinger is men weren't done with her.
They were going to come from,
she said they're going
to kill me in there.
Don't let them,
they're going to kill me.
She wasn't wrong in the hospital.
She's diagnosed with
advanced liver cancer,
um,
probably related to severe alcoholism.
Um,
and in the hospital she,
um,
she goes into heroin withdrawal.
So mainly for our managers to insist that
she's giving methadone and she starts
to recover a bit cause her McGraw's
quite dangerous when you're weak,
right?
Like when you're old or youth.
Um,
Ansley has men come,
they arrest her on her hospital bed.
They handcuffed her to the hospital.
But I interviewed the last
person who was still alive.
You've been in that room or a man called
Reverend Eugene calendar had been a
religious minister.
Um,
they handcuffed her to a hospital bed.
They don't have friends in to see her.
They don't lie or even
have candies outside.
Reverend calendar led
protests with signs saying,
Let Lady Day live.
There were big protests.
They knew they were killing her.
Right?
Um,
then after 10 days,
they cut off the methadone.
She died the next day.
Her friend,
one
of her friends told the BBC
that she looked like she
had been violently wrenched
from life.
Right?
There's loads of things about this
storage being made into a movie and Lee
Daniels is directing it.
Um,
there's so many things about this story
that tells what this war on drugs is
about,
right?
Firstly,
it's about,
um,
it's a fact.
It's about shaming addicts and its
effect as it makes that it's worse,
right?
Is that with Billie holiday?
See that everywhere.
Secondly,
it's been insanely racist from the start.
Right?
At the same time,
the Harry Anslinger found out Billy
holiday had a heroin addiction.
He found out Judy Garland,
Dorothy from the wizard of
balls had a heroin addiction.
It may change as I watched the
wizard of Oz where you know that,
um,
and he went to the
studio and he advised he,
he said to Judy Garland into the studio,
she should take longer vacations,
right spot the difference
with a white woman,
Judy Garland,
longer vacations with Billie holiday,
fucking destroy her,
right?
Uh,
if at one of the agents he sent to
destroy her and my uncle George White,
who has got a tractor in
the last days of her life,
we now know,
I mean,
he's literally a psychopath.
He was a hugely obese
guys across strange guy.
He infiltrated a Chinese drug
gang when he wasn't Chinese.
Any person to ever do that.
But he,
um,
he boasted in his diary
about murdering people,
about spiking women and raping them.
I mean,
these were really
deranged people that were,
that founded the the drug will.
But the reason I say in relation to what
we were just talking about is because
in this culture,
we tell only one heroic story about
people with addiction problems,
and that's what they sometimes
recover from their addiction.
That is indeed a heroic story.
Everyone watching this has been,
who's managed to do that is a hero and
I massively love and congratulate them,
but that is not the only heroic story we
should tell about people with addiction
problems.
Billie holiday never stopped using drugs.
She was still a fucking hero.
She any,
she never let these people
stop her singing that song.
She would go to the places
where you didn't have a license,
you'd go to the worst
parts of the deep south.
She sang strange fruit.
They people threw bottles at had
they stopped out cigarettes on her.
She never stopped singing that song.
Right?
And I think about Billie Holiday a lot.
And I think about,
you know,
all over the world,
every day people listen to Billie holiday
and they feel stronger and all over
the world,
every day we are still
following the policies of
Harry Anslinger and it makes us
weaker.
And this conflict that begins
right at the start of the drug.
And I think if I'm honest,
I think this isn't an easy thing to say,
but I think one of the reasons why the
debate about the drug wars so charged is
because it runs through
the hearts of all of us,
right?
Anyone who's got someone they love
has got an addiction problem as I do
a Harry Anslinger in your head,
right?
There's a bit of view that looks at them
and thinks someone should just fucking
stop here.
Why are you doing this?
Someone should stop you doing this.
And then for most people,
there's another part that's like,
okay,
that anger isn't useful in most cases.
Um,
actually what you're
doing this for a reason.
We need to understand those reasons.
We need to help you to change your life,
right?
But that conflict is,
is,
is very deep in us.
And Harry Anslinger the war he invented.
And we can talk about what he did with
cannabis and lots of other things,
but because he invented
the ban on cannabis,
that that war is,
is still playing it.
Does that make sense?
I know that was a long answer,
but that's all right.
No,
it does make sense of it.
It's a horrific story about Billy all day.
And I had no idea that I'm Dorothy from
the wizard of Oz was also addicted.
Did you?
The munchkins a lot of them as well.
Now,
Harry W W W why was Harry Anslinger
is hate towards her so extreme.
So when he was a kid,
the book is called chasing the screen.
Cause when he was a kid,
he grew up in a place called
Altoona in Pennsylvania.
And he,
he lives in a farm house.
His Dad was actually a refugee from swell
refugee and a bit comes immigrant from
Switzerland.
Um,
and they grew up in this farm house.
And in the next farm
house down there was a,
a,
um,
a farmer's wife.
You had an a heroin addiction or methods,
sorry,
morphine addiction
would've been hiring them.
And Harry Anslinger had this really
haunting memory of going to that house and
hearing this woman's scream and scream
and him being sent to take the wholesome,
I think it was 11 or
something being sent to tight,
the Holston caught into town to go to
the pharmacy to get her the morphine and
then bringing it back in her scream,
stopping.
The lesson he took from that is these
drugs are evil and we need to destroy
them.
Especially later on.
He,
he was in Europe during the first
world war and he had this very keen,
was a diplomat.
We had this very keen sense that
civilization was incredibly fragile.
It could collapse at any moment,
that you only need a little bit of
contamination and it will all go to shit.
Um,
and,
and so he,
yeah,
I call it chasing the screen.
Cause I think in a way what
Harry Anslinger is doing
is like chasing the scream
all over the world.
And I felt like,
well,
I was doing,
going to all these different places
from the killing fields in Mexico to
Portugal.
And Switzerland was like,
following this scream as it
kind of ricocheted around.
And actually how he made he thinks
he's stopping these screams is actually
creating far more screams in their,
in their,
in their place.
Yeah.
But I still don't understand why
he had this intensity holiday so,
well,
she's an African American woman standing
up to white supremacy who has an
addiction problem.
But the truth is what he did to
Billie holiday is not a party.
It's not,
this is what you did to African Americans
and people with addiction problems.
Billie holiday.
It happens to be famous.
So I'm telling her story,
but this is what he did
to huge numbers of people,
right?
He wanted to destroy the whole jazz scene.
One of the amazing thing
is spending time in his,
um,
archives in Penn state was
seeing all these memos from,
uh,
his agents.
We said to them,
go to your local jazz club,
document the evil things that happening
there and the things they wrote back.
I caught a hilarious,
right,
there's one agent who,
I forget where it was,
but he wrote back and was like,
um,
there was a popular jazz
song at the time called,
uh,
that ocean ma'am,
and had a lyric that said,
when he gets the notion,
he thinks he can walk across the ocean.
And he's like,
there was gonna be an epidemic of drowning
across the United States as people
use cannabis because they're going
to believe they can walk on water.
So he would,
he was like,
look,
you're the hilarious.
We were things he said,
you know,
he believed that when you smoke cannabis,
time slows down.
So a minute seems to
last a thousand years.
Like these extraordinarily heightened,
crazy things that he would,
he would say.
And he actually latched.
So at that time when he first takes
over what becomes the Federal Bureau of
narcotics,
you know,
cocaine and heroin start very popular,
right?
There's just not much of a war to fight.
I mean,
they exist,
but they're not that popular quite
that can find a small urban scenes.
Cannabis was more popular,
not as popular as it is now,
but an,
and he had previously said,
cannabis isn't harmful,
not bothered about it.
He suddenly,
when he cottons on that,
this is the way to big
buildup his department,
he announces that cannabis is,
the phrase he used was the
most evil drug in the world.
He said when Frankenstein's monster
bumps into a spliff on the staircase,
Frankenstein's monster dies of fright,
like at extraordinarily heightened claims.
Um,
and,
and any,
any issues just trying to get
support for a ban on cannabis.
And he latches onto
one case in particular.
I some point,
cause I think we're hearing these again,
these things again now.
Um,
so a kid in Tampa,
Florida called Victor Lacarta,
who was not so much a kid,
21 killed his entire family with an ax,
but should the mall and with the
help of the Fox News of its time,
Hearst,
Hearst newspapers,
uh,
Anslinger announces this is what
will happen if you use cannabis.
Literally,
you will kill your family with an ax.
Right?
And this becomes a very famous
story across the United States.
And cannabis is banned in its wake.
Years later,
someone goes and checks the psychiatric
files for bit till I kind of,
it wasn't even evidence
it'd be used cannabis,
right,
is he'd had terrible
problems with psychosis.
His family had been advised more
than a year before that he should be
institutionalized and they refused.
They kept him at home.
And this tragedy ensued.
We're hearing these,
these scare stories again about,
about cannabis as something that Anslinger
said that I think could be like the
motto for the entire drug war in the
wake of the Anslinger introduces this ban
in the u s he promises
drugs will disappear,
right?
You will notice drugs did not disappear.
He starts to say,
well that's just cause evil.
Foreign countries like Mexico are
flooding our country with drugs.
You'll notice that's come back as well.
Um,
so what we need to do is force all these
other countries to band them as well,
and then they'll disappear.
So the u s in the wake of the Second
World War where it has the power to do
that,
the world is in ruins.
Um,
and there's one point when he goes to
the new United Nations and he's insisting
this happens and they're
basically threatening people.
They're saying,
we'll cut off your foreign aid or you
won't be allowed to sell goods to the US
market if you don't do this.
The ambassador from Thailand is like,
well,
you know,
it doesn't seem to work
very well in your country.
We've actually got a long pattern
of established drug use in,
in Thailand.
We don't really have many problems.
We don't want to do this and answer thing.
I said to her,
I said to him,
I've made up my mind,
don't try to confuse
me with the facts.
And I always feel like
that's the drug war.
Right.
And made up my mind,
don't try to confuse me with the facts.
While he,
in conjunction with a
William Randolph Hearst,
he worked with him to try to propagate
these ridiculous propaganda stories about
Mexicans and blacks smoking
this evil drug called marijuana,
which is really not even a real
term for cannabis at the time.
It was a sound.
It's wild.
Yeah.
It was a wild Mexican tobacco,
right?
Yeah.
Um,
but then didn't Nixon do a similar thing
with the sweeping psychedelic act of
1970 he did it so that they
could infiltrate the civil
rights movement because
there were so many people in the civil
rights movement that we're using various
psychedelic drugs.
They could use it as an excuse to crack
down on them and lock them up and put
them in jail and pit them
against each other and you know,
have them inform on each other.
Yeah.
This is really important.
You cannot enforce the drug laws
against everyone who's broken than it is
impossible.
Half of all Americans by conservative
estimate of broken the drug laws.
Right.
So what do you do everywhere in the world?
The drug laws are used
to persecute groups.
The state wants to persecute
him for other reasons,
right?
Yeah.
So one of the people I wrote about
in chasing the scream is a wound.
He really had a kind
of epiphany about this,
right?
So Lee Maddox was a cop in Baltimore.
She used to do the [inaudible] she would,
and she would very proudly bust
people who even had a single joint.
Right.
She was a real Harry
answering his dream go.
And she had signed up to become a cop,
which is amazing.
Interesting.
Personally,
she'd signed up to come cop for
quite personal reason as a kid.
She'd had a best friend,
couldn't teenager called Elisa.
Uh,
he was like,
they looked really similar.
They shared a fake Id.
They were like sisters.
And one day when they
were in the late teens,
they went to ocean city for day out and
Lisa decided to hitchhike back to New
Jersey where she lived.
And uh,
so Lisa bye to her and the next
day she gets a call saying,
Lisa had not arrived.
So she waits and way.
It's just this terrible summer
waiting to find out what happened.
And then they discovered that Lisa had
been gang raped and murdered at body,
was found underneath the house
where had been eaten by animals.
Um,
and Lee becomes,
became convinced at that time that,
that Lisa had for spares reasons that
Lisa had been killed as part of a gang
initiation ceremony.
She's like,
she's like,
I'm going to destroy these gangs,
going to dedicate my life
to destroying these gangs.
She goes and applies to become a police
officer and for years she's this,
you know,
hardline cop,
right?
It takes real pleasure in busting people,
but least started to notice a few things.
First thing was,
um,
when you were a cop and
you arrest a rapist,
there are fewer rapes in
your town the next week,
right?
When you are copying,
you bust a pedophile,
fewer children get sexually abused,
but she knows when you bust a dealer,
there's no fewer dealers.
There's someone on the
corner the next day for sure,
right?
It didn't seem to be having any effect.
In fact,
what she discovered while she was,
she began to learn about this
was that there was something,
uh,
even worse,
which was,
um,
if for any sort of reason
that she realized that she
was actually creating these
empowering these gangs.
So the best way to explain
this is if you imagine,
obviously when you,
when you ban drugs,
they don't disappear,
right?
That transferred from the people
who are used to control them,
licensed legal businesses
to armed criminal gangs,
right?
And these aren't criminal gangs
operate in a different way to,
to,
to legal businesses.
So if you imagine if you and me decided
we want to go and steal now a bottle of
vodka,
right?
We're going to local liquor
store and that store catches us,
they'll call the cops.
The cops will come and take us away.
That liquor store doesn't
need to be violent.
It doesn't need to be intimidating.
They've got the power of the law
to uphold their property rights.
Can now imagine we were
to steal a bag of coke,
right?
If we go to the guy near here,
I'm sure there is someone who,
who,
um,
sells coke,
and he catches us.
He can't call the cops.
Obviously cops would arrest him.
He has to fight us.
Now if you're a dealer,
you don't want to be
having a fight every day,
right?
You want to establish a reputation for
being so frightening that no one would
dare to fuck with you,
right?
So you,
you establish your place in that
neighborhood through aggression,
through violence,
and you maintain it through
aggression and violence,
right?
Uh,
legal businesses compete on cost and
quality of product in illegal markets.
People compete on how much of a
frightening fucker you're prepared to be,
right?
And as a writer called
Charles Bout and put it,
the war on drugs creates a war for drugs,
right?
It transfers it to these criminal gangs
who have to operate through violence to
protect their property rights.
So link goes into the drug war thinking
I'm the one stopping these gangs.
She realizes she,
I'm the one enabling them,
right?
They control one of the biggest industries
in the world because of this police
action.
And because of this decision
to prohibit these drugs,
and if you want to know how much
of this violence is caused by,
by,
um,
by the fact that we prohibited it,
just ask yourself,
where are the violent alcohol dealers,
right?
Everyone knows who al Capone was.
Does the head of Smirnoff go and shoot
that had a Budweiser in the face?
Right?
Does your local bar go and send a bunch
of kids to go and shoot everyone in the
next bar down?
Of course not exactly that happened
and the alcohol prohibition,
when did it end ended on the day alcohol
prohibition ended because legal markets
don't compete with that.
So at least partly having this insight,
right?
She's realizing,
Shit,
I think I'm taking down these gangs.
I'm actually empowering them.
What will really disempowered them as
reclaiming the market and making it legal.
But she also has another
really painful realization.
So early in her career as a cop,
Lee had done this really brave thing.
She'd gone undercover with
the clan to expose them.
She'd done a really important work in
breaking up parts of the Maryland clam.
She really was not a racist,
right?
She'd had relationships
with African American men,
but she knows something
that most on is cops notice,
which is the vast majority of people,
the,
they were sent to African areas to enforce
the drug laws.
Right.
One of our colleagues,
Matthew fog,
once went to his superior
officer and said,
you know,
this is a bit weird,
right?
We only ever seem to go to African
American neighborhoods to do all our drug
busts.
I'm fairly sure white
people sometimes use drug.
Should we go to like a
white neighborhood as well?
And the supervisor said,
of course you're right.
White people use drugs,
but white people,
no journalists and lawyers and judges.
That's really,
we that's just get a
whole load of shit for us.
Just go for the low hanging fruit.
So Lee who is not a racist,
could see the effect of what she
was doing was in fact racist.
Right.
And she was very uncomfortable with that.
And this really came to a head Billy
when Lee's police partner was guy called
Ed.
Totally.
Who she loved.
Platonically loved.
Um,
yeah,
he was a great champion
of women police officers.
It was a great guy.
And one day she gets a call at home.
Ed had been sent on a drug bust.
He was undercover and uh,
the guy had thought it was ripping
him off and shot him in the head.
And lead goes to see eds body.
And she's like,
what did he die for?
Right?
There are no fewer drug dealers.
Every time we arrest the drug dealer,
the supply of drugs is not
disrupted for one hour.
We are enforcing a racist war.
We are empowering these gangs.
Why are we doing this?
So Lee quit as a police officer,
she retrained as a lawyer.
She now gets the criminal records
expunged wherever she can have the kind of
people that she busted when
she was a cop and she's a big,
she was part of the brilliant group
called law enforcement against prohibition
who are cops who argue
for ending the drug war.
But it's interesting to me because it's
hard to be Harry Lee was trying to be
Harry Anslinger is hard to
be Harry Anslinger if you're
an honest person with a
conscience,
right?
And there are police officers all
over the country who are making these,
these,
these realizations now and that,
you know,
obviously it's very close to my heart,
what we do to people
with addiction problems.
I don't.
Horrific and catastrophic though.
That is,
I don't actually think that's the biggest
moral issue around the war on drugs.
The biggest moral issue is the
violence created by prohibition,
right?
If I think about places I've
spent time like Columbia,
um,
see it at Horace in,
in northern Mexico,
that's the biggest issue,
right?
More people have died in,
in Latin America,
central and South America,
in the drug war,
violence than have died in Syria.
I don't know what we can do about Syria.
We can end this violence as
professor at Harvard could.
Jeffrey Myron [inaudible] has a graph of
the murder rate in the 20th century in
the United States,
massively shoots up the day.
Alcohol is banned and fools like a stone.
The day alcohol is legalized,
right?
And massively rises again when there's
an intensification of the drug war later,
um,
we can end a huge amount of this violence,
right?
We can do what Switzerland did.
We can do what,
what's happening here
and what's stopping us.
So I think the main thing is this is a
logical conclusion based on facts and
based on cases like
Portugal and Switzerland,
there's obviously data.
So people are aware of this.
So people must be
confronted with this data.
To this day,
people know that the prohibition on
alcohol was a massive disaster and no one
would ever accept it again.
We're slowly starting to
realize that marijuana,
at least for some people is,
is safe and reasonable and should be
used recreationally and has some massive
benefits medically.
So we're starting to see legalization
both for recreational use and,
uh,
clearly for medical uses spread.
I think,
what did we decide what it was?
It,
I think it's like there's a certain amount
of states where it's just fully legal
recreationally and more
where it's medical,
but I think it's more
than 18 states total knee.
As soon we're going to be half of the
American population should be 100%.
I mean,
we all is in Canada and it should be,
yes it is in Canada as
it should be for alcohol.
But what,
what is the stop?
What is the wall between this and
legalization of all these other drugs and
counseling and implementing some
sort of a Switzerland like program?
The think going to the
really important question.
So there's a range of things.
Um,
this is a public perception.
A big one.
I think you've gone to the most important,
right?
So some people say it's the vested
financial interest in the existing system.
That's true.
If you look at who funds the no campaigns,
whenever they want to legalize marijuana,
you can see the interest,
right?
Prison guard unions,
um,
alcohol companies cause they didn't
want a commercial competitor.
Um,
religious fundamentalist
groups like Mormons,
not the all Mormons fundamentalist,
but the grips that funding this are,
um,
so it's partly that,
but I think you're right.
I don't think that's the
main thing that's going on.
It's,
it's significant and real,
but it's the main thing that's going on.
The main thing,
the main block is
huge.
Majority of Americans,
more than 80% said the war on drugs
has failed and been a disaster.
And yet most people are
afraid of the alternatives.
Right?
And that's pot setting.
There's two things going on.
There's ignorance about what
the alternatives actually mean.
So re one of the reasons why chasing
sqream is written as I went to all these
places from the killing fields in northern
Mexico to Switzerland is because way
too often in this debate we talk
like we're a philosophy seminar.
People go,
or what would legalization mean?
How would it work?
And they go into this weird abstract
conversation like fuck that.
Here's a plane ticket to Geneva,
here's a plane ticket to Lisbon
is a plane ticket to Colorado,
right?
It's not rocket science.
Right?
I've been to the places that
have tried these things.
We can see the results,
right?
Then they're not legalization is not
an APP or decrement decriminalization.
I explain the difference if
you want are not abstract.
What's the key differences between
legalization and decriminalization?
Decriminalization is where
you stop punishing users,
but they still have to go to armed
criminal gangs to get their drug.
Legalization is where you open up some
legal route for people to get their
drugs.
And that's varies according to the drug,
right?
So I guess the kind of headline would
be decriminalization shuts down.
Orange is the new black and legalization
shuts down breaking bad and Naacos
right.
And of course we need to do,
but you're throwing to decriminalize
use and legalize supply.
Mexico decriminalize a lot of
drugs like fairly recently.
Yes.
That a big supreme court decision aspect.
A lot of time in Mexico.
And I think about,
I think about this time I
spent in Mexico really often
because it was,
I'm going to cover it.
I,
you know,
I've been to a lot of bad places.
I covered the war in the Congo.
I've been to Iraq,
I've been to Gaza.
I've never seen anything like
what happened to horrors when,
when I was there,
the,
you know,
I think it's worth explaining.
So when you,
like I was saying,
when you ban drugs that it disappear,
right?
The transfer to armed criminal gangs.
If you live in a housing project in the
United States where 5% of the economy at
that housing project is in the
hands of armed criminal gangs,
that's going to be a shitty,
frightening place to be right place.
I see it at Horace,
uh,
which is on the border with Mexican side
of the United States border with them.
It's the other side with our Paso.
Um,
by the time I went there,
it was 70%,
seven 0% of the economy was in the
hands of these armed criminal gangs.
Right.
So I remember
going to see this guy,
Ross Saleo Retta,
uh,
interview people about him and horrors.
But then I went to,
he's in prison in the United States
is in Tyler County and Rosalia it's
interesting guys.
He butchered or beheaded about 70
people between the ages of 13 and 17 to,
um,
I'm going into the prison
actually to see him.
And the guard said to me on the way in,
but obviously I can't leave you
alone with him cause he's like,
but shit,
all these people,
I was like,
oh great,
thanks.
And we have about five minutes until
around the guard was fucking God.
But I'm just saying we've Rosario
talking about his life and his,
his story.
So Rozalia grew up in Laredo,
Texas side of the border.
It's basically the same places.
Nuevo Laredo on the,
on the Mexican side.
It was pretty easy to cross
the border at that time.
Secret he was growing
up in the late nineties.
Noughties remember Sally,
I was 13 so loads get,
the designers were kind of
famous drug gang at that time.
They still are a good drug cartel.
How does Etas were created?
It's an insane story.
Every tax payer should know.
The US government decided to train
and elite anti drug force for the,
for the Mexican government,
right?
Like kind of navy seals for the anti-drug
force or they take them to Fort Bragg.
They spent something like
$250 million training them up.
They go back to Mexico.
Six months later they
all defected on mass.
Almost all of them.
I created a drug cartel.
There's Zetas,
great.
Use your tax money.
Um,
so the status where this kind of
a glamorous in inverted commas,
drug gang operating on that part of the
border drug routes move around according
to where they put policing.
It always gets through,
but it moves around,
they call it the balloon effect.
Imagine a balloon half
full of a push down,
one pace,
the air comes up somewhere else.
But at that time it was going through uh,
acquirers and our Paso and Laredo,
Nuevo Laredo and Russell.
Leo says to stories about how raw
Saleo gets involved with the Zetas.
What Russell Leo says,
he was basically kidnapped by them,
are forced to start people.
I don't think that's true.
If you look at the evidence,
it's that he sort of volunteered base 13,
so I don't hold him morally
responsible for that.
But either way,
there's one night it all begins.
He's taken on the Mexican side of the
border to a warehouse where they are
torturing people,
burning them alive.
He's given a gun by guy
called Miguel Trevino,
who later became the head of the Zetas
and he's told to shoot someone in the
head.
And that's the moment you're in.
And when you're in with the Zetas,
you'd never get out,
right.
No one leaves.
Um,
no one leaves alive.
And so they begin to train him.
He sent to us in 2005 he sent to a summer
camp that's literally account for the
teachers.
You had to behead people and do all sorts
of things and he's then sent him in in
his friends are then sent to um,
murder people is with friends,
Jessie and Gabriel,
they murder huge numbers that they were
called within the Zetas called these
child soldiers the expendables,
cause they don't give a
shit if they live or die.
Right.
The,
the,
this one person said to me,
they prefer children because they
don't understand death so well.
Right.
Obviously is for solid,
got a bit older.
He understood death better.
All his friends get murdered,
eventually tries to get back
to the u s he cooperates.
He now lives in solitary confinement
where he will live by the rest of his life
because when they let him out of solitary,
shortly before I met him,
he was immediately stabbed in the neck.
Um,
and again,
you think about this insane
violence that we created,
right?
When I went to Hawaii,
it's,
it's this bizarre thing.
So that time it wasn't,
you were told it wasn't quite rightly,
it wasn't safe to stay
in horror as overnight.
So I would stay overnight in El Paso
and I'd walk across the bridge right
through three through share passport,
remember the customs people going,
what the fuck are you going into horrors,
but go,
go in there.
It's weird.
On on the other side of the bridge,
there's this sign and it says
welcome to historic downtown Juarez.
And it used to be a tourist site.
Billie holiday got married there.
But um,
now it's just that time it was just
covered with images of missing women,
just everywhere.
Because this is another really important
part of what this violence doesn't
think.
It's really important.
We understand this is the violence caused
by the system that we uphold and we
imposed on Mexico.
Mexicans do not want this.
Right?
So there's another story.
I think there's just of all the stories
I wrote about for chasing the scream
along with one other one I can
tell you about if you want.
This was the hardest.
So women in horrors.
Um,
when the drug war violence starts to go
through called Maricella Escobedo she
was a,
a nurse,
but Marissa was incredibly hardworking.
So she also would do these,
um,
I would call it like
woodcarvings basically,
and she would sell them in the
market on Saturdays and Sundays.
She had three kids.
Our youngest daughter was called Ruby.
She was 14 at the time and they would
work on this stall in the marketplace.
Um,
every Saturday I think
they'd been Sundays as well,
some Sundays.
And one day a guy comes up to my
reseller that has store called Sergio.
He was young guy,
he was like 21.
Um,
and he's like,
he just had a baby.
He a job.
Marcella was kind of soft hearted.
She gives him a job working
on her market stall.
And a few months later she discovers to
her horror that he's having sex with a
14 year old daughter,
Ruby.
And she's like,
fires him immediately and it
goes to the police and says,
you need to go and question him.
Right.
He's 21,
she's 14.
This is a crime.
Police don't do anything.
She doesn't understand it.
What,
why are they not investigating this?
Her daughter starts running
away to be with w with Sergio.
Um,
Maricella keeps going to get her back.
She keeps going to the police
saying this is a crime.
Can't live with a 14 year old go and
arrest of they won't do anything.
Right.
She completely puzzled by this.
Then Ruby gets pregnant.
Marcel is like fishes 15
by then it's like fuck,
I've got to keep her in my life.
So she,
she keeps going to see ruby.
By this time she's kind of accepted the
police on with real rage that police
aren't going to do anything.
And then one day just
after the baby was born,
she goes to see Ruby and Sergio's
there with the baby and he says,
I'm a ruby has run away with another man.
She's gone.
She's not coming back.
And varicella is like what?
And left her baby.
No,
she hasn't done.
I know she hasn't done that.
No.
My daughter,
he's like,
well she's gone.
So Mary's cell awaits.
Christmas comes,
no message.
New Year comes,
She starts to go to the neighborhood and
hand out leaflets with pictures of our
daughter.
Loads of women are going missing.
And Horace at this time I,
Taiwan minute,
I'm just saying,
have you seen this go.
And after a few days she gets a call
from a kid called an hale who says,
I'm really frightened
to tell you something.
If you drive me out into the desert,
I'll tell you.
So she drives an hell out into the desert.
He was 14.
Um,
and he says,
um,
Sergio murdered your daughter.
And he made me help him
dispose of the body.
And he told Maricella where the body was.
It was actually a place where they
dumped a pig carcasses from the AB 12.
She goes and she finds the body with a son
and she goes to the police and the police
finally do something and they arrest
Sergio.
Sergio's put on trial in the witness box.
He breaks down,
admits he did it and
apologizes to Maricella.
And then a few weeks later he's
acquitted of all charges and disappears.
And Marisol is like,
what the fuck is going on here?
So she starts to look into
this and she discovers,
and this is the work intersects with
the drug war and a really important way
that the Sergio was a member of the Zetas.
Right now,
if you remember the Zetas at that time
in horror as his different acts and other
drug gangs displaced them,
you own the state,
right?
And you have,
if they control 70% of the economy,
you have more money than the government.
Right?
So the police work.
Then when I went to go into be Rozalia,
he said when I would go mare to people,
the police would,
would come with me.
They would dispose of the body.
Right.
Remember to great.
And what year are we talking about?
This is like six years ago.
I remember the,
the,
the tea.
I'm a bit,
isn't it?
Because one of the things when
you're in a dangerous place,
when you're,
when you're in a dangerous place,
one of the things you do is you read
danger from how frightened the people
around you are.
Right?
Because you don't know the place I was.
I mean,
I was there with Julio
and Cardona is my fixer.
He's an amazing,
he's the Reuters corresponded choir is
one of the bravest people I've ever met.
But it was realizing how frightened
other people were for me and Julio on,
right?
And I remember after I'd
been there for a few days,
helion kept introducing me.
By that time,
the killings were basically all being
done by the police and it was saying,
you know,
Julio,
this is,
this is important that I meet people
who've been killed by the police,
but I should also meet people who've
been killed by the cartels more recently.
And he said that he just laughed and said,
no,
that's,
that's not how it works here.
I had now if the cartels
want to kill someone,
they just pay the police to do it,
right?
So it's this real realization,
all right,
if someone comes to you,
there is nowhere for you to go,
right?
So Mary refuses to accept that she lives
in a country where there is no justice.
She decides,
okay,
they're not going to solve this.
I'm going to solve this.
She appealed.
Look at loads of women are missing because
it turns out if a bunch of criminals
control the state,
they will just murder loads
of women and get away with it,
right?
There are some men who
just want to murder women,
and if they give them license to do it,
they'll do it.
That's why so many women we're missing.
Maricella gathers a load of those mothers.
She says,
some of them don't know
where their daughters are.
Some of them know their
daughters are dead.
She's like,
I need your help.
We're going to find this
guy who's done this right?
So Maricella turns herself with
these women into a detective.
She starts tracking
Sergio all over Mexico,
wherever there are sightings,
she walks everywhere.
She walks over a thousand miles,
right?
She walks through the desert.
It becomes a media phenomenon.
People follow her.
She's like this,
this symbol of the loss that's happened
in Mexico and incredibly with a friend,
Berta,
Alysia Garcia,
who I got to know later,
after two years,
she finds Sergio.
She tracks him down.
She goes to the police,
she tells them where he is,
they tip him off and he disappears.
I,
she's devastated.
So she decided she's going to go to
the governor's mansion in Chihuahua,
uh,
which the state capitol.
She goes there and she sets up 10 outside
the governor's mansion and she's like,
I'm not leaving here until you
people go and find this man.
And she calls on every mother who has a
daughter who's missing or they're afraid
of four to come and
join her in this fight.
Right?
And it gets to Christmas Eve and she's
preparing to it just before Christmas
isn't Christmas Eve.
I'm going to have this
big Christmas dinner here.
People can join me.
She gives this great
speech and a man walks up,
turn sheets are in the head
in front of all the police,
everyone,
and
to a lot about Maricella.
I got to know her children who live here
in the United States now they've got
a refugee.
When I think about the
drug war and what it does,
yeah,
the first person I think I've after
Billie holiday's Marisella Escobedo right.
We have created an enormous amount of
violence that has nothing to do with the
drug.
Right?
Often people will hear this phrase,
drug related violence and
what they picture when they
hear that is someone using
drugs,
losing shit and attacking someone.
Right?
There's a really good study
by a guy called professor
Paul Goldstein that looked
at everything.
It was classified as drug related
violence in New York City in 1986 what it
found was 3% of what's called drug related
violence is someone using drugs and
losing their shit.
That's real.
It happens sometimes 2% 3% another 7%
was people with an addiction problem like
committing property crimes and
getting caught or whatever,
and the vast majority was rival drug
gangs and exactly the kind of violence
we're talking about,
the war for drugs created by prohibition.
Now we can reduce the problems
associated with drug use by having,
these are just,
they have in Switzerland to Portugal and
we can end the violence caused by the
war for drugs.
There are no violent alcohol gangs.
Al Capone killed loads of people,
drug,
no alcohol seller anywhere in the United
States today will kill a single other
alcohols seller,
right?
That violence ended.
If we banned rice,
there will be violent rice sellers,
right?
We have to understand
that what we are doing,
and there's this bullshit fucking thing
that said where they'll take these debts
on the supply route,
right?
Prohibitionists and they'll say,
look at you,
evil drug users,
your responsible for the
deaths of these people.
Right?
And to me that is so punishes,
right?
You could have every single drug piece
of druggies that happened in the United
States today and none of those
killings on the supply route.
It is the system those people have
erected and imposed and lied their way to
maintain the causes,
this violence.
Right?
And we can end this violence.
And I think about the Rosario,
right?
That,
that,
you know,
I got asked once in an interview,
who do you feel most sorry for?
Of all the people you met.
And obviously I met people with
addiction problems all over the world,
I think.
And I surprised myself,
the person who came into
my head was Rozalia because
we'll have we done to these people.
Right.
Well it's not we for sure.
Yeah.
As taxpayers we are responsible for it.
Right?
I mean we don't,
you know,
you and I do not support it,
but,
um,
as a society we,
we've done that and those of us who were
pose it haven't done a good enough job
of persuading.
When else,
and it goes back to your question,
why does it persist?
Right.
The key reason I think it's two things.
Partly people are afraid of the
alternatives for understandable reasons.
There are real risks in
pursuing the alternatives.
Uh,
I think we can understand what
those were signed deal with them,
but that bounce that,
hold on because it seems like those
risks have been mitigated in Portugal and
Switzerland.
I mean we have real evidence that
those risks and there are unfounded.
Exactly.
You can understand it's not
crazy to have that fear,
but then we can address that fear by
talking about what actually happened.
Well,
why don't we implement some sort
of a small scale version of this.
I mean,
how come no one has ever tried to do this?
You mean do it in Vermont?
Do it in New Hampshire doing a small
state where there are loads of people who
want to do that.
But the federal drug laws are federal,
right?
So federal law supersedes,
um,
I'm at,
that doesn't happen with cannabis.
So that was a,
that's a big debate technically
and legally the federal
government could go off
this Colorado,
Washington.
Now there's a political decision to not
do that because cannabis legalization is
popular in those places
right there where people,
Jeff sessions when he was the ag one,
it's a general wanting,
wanting to do that.
It's just our good luck that actually
he pissed off Trump over something else.
The cause,
the cause of the meter inquiring
everything that Trump kind of,
despite Jeff sessions didn't line.
So the federal banking
laws actually mean that,
you know,
cannabis stores are operating
in this weird gray area.
They can't have bank account.
My point is,
why is no one pushing this?
Why?
Why is the world people are pushing that?
Yeah.
So I think there are lots of
people who are pushing this.
The amazing groups urge everyone to join
and support the drug policy alliance on
the,
what I'm saying is why are no
politician's ever discussing this?
This is never an option because those are
the only ones that are going to really
change policy.
So we're seeing a big change in public
opinion that is changed on many issues.
So think about when Bill
Clinton stopped being president,
which is,
you know,
we remember there's not that long ago,
16% of Americans supported
legalizing cannabis.
Today 70% of Americans
support legalizing cannabis.
So extraordinary transformation,
a very short period of time,
right?
Likely brought on by the fact that the
medical use of it was prohibited up until
then.
I mean it was like 1994
right when it was passed.
And then California has started doing
it and then you started having positive
tax revenues from it and you started
seeing people that were suffering from a
lot of ailments showing that they
were helped substantially by cannabis.
And then the attitude of it
changed in popular culture.
It changed.
I mean the,
what's so crazy is that
that reefer madness,
reaper,
reefer madness proposition or the,
uh,
um,
propaganda rather was so effective that
they did it in the 1930s and it carried
on into the 90s into the two thousands.
There's still people alive
today to believe some of that.
I think you put that really well.
I think as a series of things going on,
partly what happened,
one of the major,
one of the major factors that make it
possible for the drug war to continue is
the dehumanization of
people at every turn.
Right?
Got The dehumanization of drug users.
And it's funny we should talk
about use as opposed to addiction,
but um,
dehumanization of drug users,
dehumanization of people
with addiction problems,
dehumanization of drug dealers.
There's a reason why one of the most
sympathetic people in my book is a
transgendered crack dealer
called Chino Harden.
He's an amazing human
being and dehumanization of
people on the supply route
countries.
You're hearing the way people are talking
about Mexicans now of powerful people
in this society.
And one of the reasons why chasing the
scream is written as stories of people
is because the solution to
dehumanization is to re humanization.
When I was meeting these
people all over the world,
I kept thinking
if any ordinary American could
meet Chino harder and my friend,
that transgender crack dealer
who is hilarious and amazing,
if they could meet Bud Osborne,
the homeless street addict who
started a movement in Canada,
um,
if they could meet Maricella,
they would not say that the deaths
of these people mean nothing,
right?
They would not say,
yeah,
let's pursue a policy that kills them
cause we get some imaginary benefit
further down the line.
Right?
Think about Lee Maddix,
the cop in Baltimore.
It was when Ed died.
It was when her partner does Sheila,
what are we losing these people for?
It's that moment or getting people
to see everyone involved as human,
right?
We're not there yet.
Still the ways people are
talking about addiction are,
oh,
repellent,
right?
This is the thing of people as being weak.
I think of people's having poor willpower,
poor character,
and that's why they're addicted.
They're most people.
I would,
I would say it's safe to venture,
aren't really fully
aware of what the causes,
what the underlying causes of people
becoming addicted to drugs in the first
place are and what,
what leads people this
great sense of despair.
I mean it's really about
reengineering our entire culture.
I mean reengineering not just
the way we treat addiction,
but the way we treat human beings
where we treat poor neighborhoods.
I mean there's,
there's so much that needs to be done
that's never dressed totally right.
And this one part of this,
this a funny
really one of the surprises me in this
debate I have found is actually easier in
the u s to make the case for compassion
for people with addiction problems than
to make the case for liberty for
drug users who are not addicted.
Right.
So like we were saying,
even the main drug war body in the world,
the UN ODC,
you're an office of drug control admits
90% of all currently banned drug uses.
What's called non problematic,
right?
Our friend,
professor call heart is the head of
psychology at Columbia University and an
extraordinary human being has done
really important work explaining this to
people,
even with what we think of as the
devil drugs like heroin crack.
The vast majority of people who use
heroin and crack do not become addicted.
Right.
Which I found really chat when
Carl first explain that to me.
I was like,
what's this guy talking about?
And then we looked at the
scientific evidence that
there is very clear evidence.
Right?
Um,
the,
the actually the ratio of people who use
any drug he become addicted is pretty
consistently 10 to 20%.
Right?
Slightly higher for things like heroin,
but it's pretty consistently in that zone.
Right?
Which is not to say that
there aren't other ha,
heroin depresses your breathing.
It can cause death that way.
The other harms,
but which we might addiction.
Right.
Um,
so
it's interesting.
There's so much I think we
need to explain to people.
One person here in La,
you really helped me to understand
this and the research for the book.
Biggest guy called
Professor Ronald Casey goal.
You should.
You should totally have in your shows.
A very interesting guy.
He was an advisor to
four American presidents.
He was a,
who buys it?
World Health Organization,
really serious scientists,
but he had a sideline for 30 years.
We investigated animals using drugs,
right,
and he's basically shown loads of
species love getting intoxicated for the
pleasure of it.
Right out elephants.
Elephants like this is the
amazing sample given bank.
All of elephants who broke into an
alcohol store got drunk and just fucked up
the whole village.
If you give,
if you give hash to mice,
what they do is they'll,
they get really horny.
They tried to mail most,
we'll try to mount women,
but then they basically can't get up,
so they just spend hours looking their
own balls and they're going to cock semi
loads of examples.
It's about a guy press a seagull.
I remember he told me at one point that
he'd spent three years investigating
grasshoppers in cannabis fields who just
naturally live in cannabis fields to
figure out when they eat the cannabis,
do they jump higher or lower?
And I said,
I write and at the end
of your three years,
what did you discover?
And he said,
they'd turns out they just jump
the same height as everyone,
all the other girls.
So it wasn't a great use of
your three years of life.
But he also got the,
at an interesting time
when he was in Hawaii,
he was investigating mongoose where
the mongoose is like hallucinogens,
psychedelics and he,
so he's like spying on these mongooses
with binoculars and he gets caught and he
gets caught by a load of
drug traffickers and like,
who the fuck are you?
And he's like,
don't worry.
I'm just investigating with a
mongoose is like psychedelics.
Like that is the worst fucking cupboard
story we've ever had that held them
hostage for like two days.
But what he showed is something I think
is really important and there's loads of
other evidence for which is,
um,
it is absolutely a Nate to other species,
but especially to humans,
the desire to get intoxicated,
right.
There has never been a human society
anywhere in the world where people didn't
seek out and toxicants
and enjoy using them.
The only society where there were no
naturally occurring and toxicants was the
internet,
the what we used to be called the Eskimos
in the Arctic and they used to just
starve themselves to get a fucked up head
state because that's how deep it is in
human beings.
If there is nothing in the star,
if you starve yourself long enough,
you get a kind of fucked
up head state basically.
How far,
how long are you going to go for?
I don't know.
I looked into the details of
it but he writes about that.
Um,
but but so it's fasting.
Yeah.
Fasting causes and ultra Ted state.
But the,
I've never done it but this,
this,
this intoxication in is deep and
human beings as the sexual impasse,
you even see it in small children.
You know,
when little kid,
everyone will remember this memory of
when you're a little kid and you realize
you can spin round and round and round
even though you know it will make you
sick,
you'd do it cause you
get an altered headspace.
That is one of the first expressions of
the kind of intoxication impulse or a
really nice example is for 2000 years,
a 40 miles outside of
Athens in ancient Greece,
they used to be once a year
people would meet at something,
a place called the temple of elusiveness
and it was basically burning man.
They would all use a psychedelic together.
We now know what that target bellicose,
yeah,
it was a kind of,
there's lots of different theories,
but they think it was a
kind of fungus basically.
Um,
I got rid of the name of it,
but there's been some researchers
and Simon or something.
I don't know,
I,
I want to say it wrong.
there was some kind of stuff,
I'm kind of stuff and like people
like Plato and Eric Sanders,
people say,
you know,
drugs or William Bennett,
the former drugs are saying drugs are
an attack on the foundations of Western
civilization.
Or you're like,
no.
At the actual foundations
of Western civilization that
people your holding up as
the icons,
like Plato and Aristotle were literally
getting fucked up in exactly the way you
say as an attack on them,
right?
It's this deep misunderstanding.
So this is a natural human impulse.
We are never going to get rid of it.
We want to get rid of it.
It gives people a lot of joy and pleasure.
And yet the Oscar Wilde said once,
I'm going to get the quote slightly wrong,
said it better than this,
but he said,
puritanism is the deep gnawing fear
that someone somewhere is enjoying
themselves.
And there's this puritanical hatred of,
of drug east,
right?
Um,
now some of that is understandable fears,
Matt genuine harms.
Uh,
and that's a different thing,
but a lot of it is just very deep.
Puritanism and you've really
seen it in one phrase.
We need to get,
get out of the English language
is the ridiculous phrase.
Drugs and alcohol.
It's like saying fruit and apples.
Alcohol is a drug,
right?
I'll call is easily the
deadliest drug in our culture.
Uh,
well after tobacco.
Um,
it's,
uh,
not,
it's like saying,
you know,
as my friend Steve Rolls his big campaign
on this is it's like saying metal and
iron,
right?
It's a meaningless phrase,
but it's,
you,
there's this distinction between
an alcohol and other drugs.
Is,
is a way of maintaining this drug war,
right?
Because the reality is the same proportion
of people become addicted to alcohol
has become addicted to cocaine,
right?
Same proportion.
Not Saying,
not absolute numbers can up.
We use our call.
Um,
risks from alcohol are
very similar to restroom,
other drugs,
right?
Actually,
some of them are alcohol is significantly
more dangerous than some drugs that
are currently banned.
Um,
but we with alcohol,
and it comes back to what you're saying
about why we don't change these policies
without alcohol.
Enough people.
Well,
everyone knows people who drink alcohol,
right?
And one of the reasons things changed
on cannabis is because more people came
out and talked about it.
And so you had this situation where
you've got Harry Anslinger saying,
if you use cannabis,
you'll,
you know,
kill your family with an axe.
By the time we get to the nineties enough
people know enough people have used
cannabis to go,
right.
Well Jimmy over there ain't a hot jacket
chopping his family to death with an
ax.
Right?
This is,
this is bullshit.
And I think one of the things we have
to do is encourage people to talk.
One of the weird things is the
prohibition creates a distorted picture of
overall drug use,
right?
Because loads of your listeners
might say on Facebook,
you know,
I went out on Saturday
night and I had you know,
five vodka shots and I got
hammered and had a great time.
You'd be pretty foolish
if you put on Facebook,
Oh,
a Saturday night I went out and have five
lines of coke and I had a great night.
Right?
You would be a fall.
And a lot of people I fall.
Let me ask you this,
is there a culture where there's no
demonized use of drugs or alcohol?
Is there any culture that doesn't frown
upon some drugs or have some forbidden
categories for drugs?
What they'd been those
societies throughout history,
right?
I mean now,
well,
we've got to understand it in the of the
war that Harry Anslinger imposed upon
the whole world,
right?
There was no country.
I mean,
if you think about habits of Mexico,
right?
So Mexico had,
uh,
so the 1930s Anslinger
says to the Mexicans,
you'll notice some real parallels.
What's happening now.
You guys are responsible
for our drug epidemic.
You've got to band drugs and
have a vicious war on drugs,
right?
And the Mexican government alike.
No,
we can see the policies
don't work for you.
We're not going to do it.
They had a drug saw,
a drug minister called Leopoldo Salazar.
Viagra.
They should build fucking statues.
Do.
No Man has ever been more prescient.
He explained to the Americans,
we don't wanna Bang,
cannabis is not particularly
harmful with other drugs.
We should be writing people
with compassionate care.
And if we banned drugs,
the countries get,
our country's going to be
taken over by drug lords.
Right?
No one has ever been more
right about anything.
Um,
the Americans,
the u s stock,
um,
pressuring Mexico more and more.
In the end,
they cut off.
So all opiates for pain relief used
in hospitals were manufactured in the
Americans in the United
States at that time.
They cut off the supply,
all of them.
People start dying in hospitals,
all of Mexico and agony
and the Mexicans given,
they fired this guy and they begin the
drug war and the whole journey that leads
to Ross,
Salvia Hereto,
the guy and I from the
Zetas and Marcel is death.
That that trajectory begins at that point,
and this is something we haven't
explained it I think is so important,
right?
Actually really surprised me learning
about the history of all this stuff at the
birth of the drug war,
it was intensely resisted,
right?
I think about here in La,
In Los Angeles,
it was a doctor called
Henry Smith Williams.
When heroin was band,
there was a deliberate
loophole in the law that said,
okay,
you can't sell heroin,
but doctors can prescribe it to
people with addiction problems.
Just like what happened in Switzerland,
right?
So here in La,
big heroin clinic prescribed Anslinger.
It drives him crazy.
He wants to shut it down.
So the mayor of Los Angeles stands in
front of this heroin prescription clinic
and says,
you will not shut this down.
This does a good job for us.
But answering shuts it down.
When the doctors say to the,
there's the biggest crackdown
on doctors in American history,
over 12,000 doctors are
arrested and rounded up.
Um,
when they come to the one in Portland,
Oregon,
the doctors say,
but what are we meant to do with all
these vulnerable addictive people?
And one of the agents that
go and throw them in the leg,
they'll make good fish food.
Right?
That was the attitude.
Um,
so this is resisted intensely
at the birth of the drug war.
So you had a society really recently
that had a much more mature,
exactly what you're asking about a much
more mature attitude to drug use than we
have now.
Right?
It's not that people thought
all drug use is good.
We should celebrate every
instance of drug use.
No one thinks that.
Right?
They were problems and there were,
there is some joy
associated with drug use.
That's actually the norm.
There is some pain and terrible
things associated with drug use,
which are mostly driven
by underlying harm,
but there are real homes,
the come from some drugs as well.
Um,
and most societies until very recently
had a mature appreciation of this,
right?
Really,
we are the outlier that most
societies have had licensed
in toxicants.
Um,
now of course in different
societies at different Tyler was,
I was the czar of Russia
who wanted to ban tobacco,
right?
And did terrible things to anyone
who was found with tobacco.
Different societies have had
different panics at different times,
but
we are the historical outliers,
right?
I mean,
to give you a sense of just
the United States in prisons,
2 million people,
that has never been a society that
imprisons this many of its citizens,
this higher proportion of
its citizens anywhere ever.
It's overwhelmingly
driven by the drug war,
right?
I mean the u s in prison,
so many people and the conditions in
those prisons are so terrible that the
United States is almost certainly the
first society ever were more men had been
raped.
The women pass how extreme this,
this war is,
right?
And what we do to people in what this,
what this,
the,
the conditions.
This war creates it
and it's a total historical outlier.
We are in a freak experiment.
Right?
And the one thing you can say
in defense of the drug war,
and I would give one
bit of credit for this,
is we gave it a fair shot,
right?
The United States has done
it for a hundred years.
This country has spent $1 trillion on it.
Uh,
we've imprisoned millions
of our own citizens.
We've,
we killed hundreds of thousands of
people that are conservative estimate.
We've destroyed whole countries.
Like Colombia isn't the problem now that
there's a gigantic business behind it
all from private prisons
to prison guard unions,
to the pharmaceutical industry that
would benefit from keeping most of these
drugs illegal.
So their profits continue
to rise to law enforcement.
I mean,
down the line it's,
you'd be disrupting like an evil industry,
but an industry,
I think that's a real factor,
but I don't want to overstate it.
Lots of policies have best in each factor.
What's the main factor?
The main factor is
most people are asked,
do you think the drug war has failed?
So yes.
And most people ask,
do you want to legalize any
drug other than cannabis?
Say No.
Very strong.
So education,
I think it's about,
we use the word education can give you
an example of a specific person who I
think showed a way to do this.
Um,
so in the year 2000 in Vancouver,
there was a homeless street addict
called bottles bomb and he lived in a
notorious part of Vancouver
called the downtown east side.
It,
um,
people in Vancouver Pippins Franco Nero.
No,
it's a place particular
at that time that had um,
really high,
like nightmarish opened drug scene.
Rogers,
again,
people it like in Switzerland,
people injecting in the streets,
that kind of thing.
And Bod was living homeless and he was
watching his friends die all around him.
At that time there was a
really big police crackdown.
Um,
and so people would go and like hide and
dumpsters or in alleyways to shoot up.
But obviously if you're
hiding and you overdose,
no one sees it,
you just die.
Right.
And one day bud,
um,
he learns at one of his
friends Judith had had died.
And like,
I can't just sit here and wait for
my friends to tie them for me to die.
But as bud would have put it down,
he also thought I'm a homeless junkie.
What the fuck am I going to do?
Right.
But had a really simple idea,
he gathered together a group of the other
homeless street addicts and he said,
um,
when we're not using,
which is most of the time,
even people on the streets,
what we should do is just drop a timetable
and go and look in the places where
we know people,
where we she up.
Right?
And if we see someone over,
we'll ring an ambulance,
no officials,
nothing like that.
Just us.
And loads of people had descended on
the downtown east side to come up with
problems to solve everything.
And people were very skeptical,
but they liked bud.
Ah,
okay.
What?
Duh.
So they start going and searching and um,
over the next three months,
the downtown that the death toll on
the downtown east side like had a
significant fall.
And obviously that meant people
who would have died were living,
which is a great thing,
but it also meant the addicts thought,
oh,
maybe we're not the pieces of shit.
Everyone says we are right.
Maybe we can do something.
They're like,
what else can we do?
Bud went to the library.
He learned in Frankfurt.
In Germany,
they'd opened safe injection rooms,
but like what happened in
California until they shut it down,
Anslinger shut it down when people could
go and use their drugs and be watched
by doctors and nurses and that this had
massively reduced deaths in Frankfurt.
Nothing like this had happened in the
United States since Anslinger shut it all
down,
but buds like,
okay,
we'll persuade our map.
They set up a group called van do the
Vancouver Area Network of drug users.
Okay.
The Mare was a conservative right wing
guy called Philip [inaudible] who have
been American comparison.
It's not Trump.
Mitt Romney,
rich guy from a privileged
family didn't get,
didn't know anything about addicts.
He'd,
he'd run for office saying all the local
drug addict should be located to be
taken and detained to the local military
base and Chilliwack and never let out
if she sends where he's coming from.
Right.
People are not optimistic
about persuading him.
Van Do bud,
his friends,
they decide everywhere Philipo and goes,
they're going to follow him with a
coffin and the coffin had written on it.
Who will die next?
[inaudible] before you open a
safe injection site every time.
But if I own spoken public,
one of the homeless people with addiction
problems would stand up and say he
will dine xsplit poem before
you open a safe injection site.
Um,
one day,
Dean Wilson,
one of the main people in
van do stood up and said,
do you remember Julia
who asked you recently?
He would die next.
It turned out to be her because
you haven't done it right.
This goes on for a long time.
They do loads of public actions.
They filled Oppenheimer Park,
which big park in Vancouver with a cross
more than a thousand crosses each one
representing someone who
had died of an overdose.
And they wrote the names of the people
on the crosses and one day after it's
been going on for years,
it totally tastes credit.
Filippo in just said,
who the fuck are these people?
What is this?
And he went to meet loads of the addicts.
He sat with them.
It blew his mind.
He thought people with addiction poems,
which just people who partied
too hard indulge themselves,
he was completely shocked.
He came here to the Untied
States to meet Milton Friedman,
the Nobel prize winning economist who
grown up under alcohol prohibition and
Milton Freeman Explains Drug
Prohibition to Phillip it,
but upon comes back to Vancouver and
it holds a press conference and had the
chief of police,
the coroner and a representative of
the addicts and he says something like,
I'm not going to speak again without
having the addicts here with me about
addiction because they
understand it better than me.
We're going to open the first safe
injection site in North America.
We're going to have the most compassionate
drug policies in North America.
Things are gonna change around here,
right?
The open safe injection site.
Filippo,
his right wing party is so horrified.
They de-select him as this
is the candidate and his
whole political career ends.
But a more liberal guy wins the
election in the room stays open.
Right.
In the 10 years that followed,
overdose deaths on the downtown east
side fell by 80% eight 0% right?
Average life expectancy in that
neighborhood rose by 10 years.
You just don't get figures
like that very often.
And I remember the reason I
say it in relation to change,
as you know,
a big part of what I argue in chasing the
scream animal but lost connections is,
you know,
we,
you don't write people off,
right?
But I realized I would
have written off Philipo in
right wing guy runs for saying we should
lock them all up in the military base.
Right.
You don't run off anyone.
You don't know who can be persuaded by
message of love and compassion and the
most unlikely,
one of the biggest champions of my book
is a conservative Evangelical Christian
in Mississippi.
Cool.
Christina Dennett who's doing
incredible work with this,
right.
And I thought a lot about Filippone when
I went to go and see Phillip Ahmed on
the downtown east side and he said to me,
he would sacrifice his entire political
career all over again given the chance
for this course.
And he said,
how often do you get to save thousands
of lives at the most vulnerable people?
And after I got to know Bud Osborne,
the guy who started this movement,
um,
he died.
He,
he,
uh,
and I remember,
you know,
he's only in his early sixties,
but he'd been a homeless
addict during a drug war.
It takes a toll on you.
And they sealed off the streets of the
downtown east side where bought had lived
as a homeless person and they had
this incredible memorial ceremony.
And there were loads of people at that
ceremony who knew that they were alive
because of what buttered started.
And because so many other people had
joined them and so many people who didn't
have addiction problems
that opened their hearts.
Right.
And I remember thinking that day,
you know,
when you get disheartened about
this as easy to get disheartened,
right?
This is a hundred year long drug war.
Um,
we're up against very powerful forces.
Everyone watching your show,
listening to your show is more
powerful than bud was that day,
right?
The day he started that,
It just,
by virtue of the fact they have a
device on which to listen to this,
right,
but didn't sit there thinking
someone else is going to handle this.
He didn't sit there thinking,
oh,
well this is,
we're up against these forces
that can't be defeated.
He started where he stood.
He appealed to the people around him and
it started this circle of change that,
you know,
the Canadian Supreme Court ruled because
the right wing government of Stephen
Harper tried to shut
down this injection site.
Um,
and the Canadian Supreme Court ruled
that people with addiction promise have a
right to light,
to live,
and that includes a safe place to use
their drugs that will never be taken away
now,
right?
That static is one.
But you know,
when you have nothing else,
you have a voice.
You have a human voice that you can use
to persuade other people with love and
compassion.
You can tell them stories,
you can build people's love and compassion
in the middle of this catastrophe
that we're seeing in this country
with the addiction crisis,
right?
I mean more people died last year and the
opiod crisis than all the soldiers who
died in the Vietnam war combined
in the middle of this catastrophe.
We can carry on doing
what we've been doing.
Okay.
We can carry on doing that,
then we will continue to get the
horrific results we are now getting.
We can continue to copy the
places that have failed,
right?
At the end of a hundred
year long drug war,
those cost $1 trillion.
We can't even keep drugs out of our
prisons where we have a wool perimeter and
we pay people to walk
around at the whole time.
So good luck keeping them
out of a 3000 mile border.
Right?
That will never happen.
That is a ludicrous fantasy.
He may as well take all the money that
will be spent on trying to keep drugs
out.
That way I'm burning it in a pile.
Right?
Is absurd.
There's never been such a society.
Um,
all we can start to copy the
places that have succeeded,
right?
Portugal,
Switzerland,
Urgh why Canada?
There are plenty of places that have
tried the alternatives and people who were
quite skeptical.
It's one thing that was most striking to
me and all those places is that people
who were initially skeptical
and initially thought it was crazy,
very often change their minds.
This is the consistent pattern
before it happens.
People think it's the work
of bunch of fucking Wackos.
They think why people would want to,
you know,
get everyone to use drugs and
get children to use drugs.
I think it's madness.
And then they see that that's not at all
what motivates people who want reform.
And that's not,
that's not what happens
in practice when you,
when you adopt these policies and it's
not a magic bullet and they still have
problems,
but there's been such a significant
improvement in all those places that the
resistance tends to,
I mean,
how many people arguing for
reversing the cannabis legalization?
Hey,
you don't ever hear it now.
Right?
And it's been a little bit of a
backlash and it kind of absurd.
But because it's come out repeatedly
kind of victor lie carters.
Well,
I actually had that guy,
I really tell me about why.
How did it,
we had a debate between
him and Alex parents,
Dean and a doctor,
Mike Hart from Canada.
Um,
and there's some,
there's some reality to the dangers of
cannabis use as some people that are
susceptible to schizophrenia.
Um,
and I think that there's also some,
at least anecdotal evidence that points
to the fact that some people experience
the psychotic breaks and
these schizophrenia episodes
probably directly as a
result of large dose use of Thc,
whether it's through edibles or whether
it's through smoking at some people
freak out.
I've known people,
I've known of people
that have had real issues with it.
I mean,
had a comedian here are
a couple of weeks ago,
talked about he doesn't smoke pot.
He's from Brazil.
He smoked pot,
use a vape pen,
uh,
took a bunch of hits and
was fucked up for two weeks.
There are,
there are dangers and problems,
certain pizza.
It's really important.
The case for legalizing cannabis is not
that there is no harm associated with
cannabis.
Right.
In the same way the case for
legalizing alcohol is not,
there's no homeless.
I said,
this is what Alex Bernstein is
trying to go over in his book.
I don't think he did a
good job for two reasons.
One,
because he's basically only making the
case for it to be negative and I think
there's far more evidence that cannabis
has had a positive influence on people.
It reinforces community,
it makes people more sensitive and kind.
This a thought of paranoia might actually,
it makes people more humble.
Um,
it makes sex feel better
and fix food tastes better.
There's,
there's creativity aspects
to it that are undeniable.
There's a lot of very
positive aspects to it.
For some people it's not good,
but it's like saying,
hey,
some people die when the
peanuts let's outlaw peanuts.
I think that one of your
children about peanuts.
Yeah.
I think everything you just said is,
is absolutely right.
I think there's another layer
that's going on at the same time,
a kind of below that which is really
important people to understand.
So there's this thing.
Um,
so very often people will say,
ah,
you get kind of Republican politicians.
Like,
cause I'm a colleague Thena
Rena saying it during,
when the Republican debates in 2016,
2015 maybe,
um,
we can't legalize cannabis because it's
much stronger now than it used to be.
THC content is coming up,
people smoking skunk.
It's really important to
understand why that happened.
It's because of drug prohibition.
So the day before alcohol was banned in
the u s the most popular drinks by far
were beer and wine.
Right?
In the weeks after alcohol prohibition
ended most popular drinks again,
where beer and wine as
they are today in between,
you could not get hold of bear
unwind the most popular drinks,
whiskey and Moonshine UNICA.
You think,
well
why would that be?
What's going on?
And it's because of a kind of
slightly wonky and boring thing,
but I think it's worth talking about
is called the Iron Law of prohibition.
If you imagine if we had to
smuggle the nearest bar to hit,
if we had to smuggle all the alcohol for
that bar in a wagon from the Canadian
bar,
from the Mexican border,
right from Tijuana
in a wagon,
we fill our wagon with bear,
we're going to get drink for 400 people.
If we fill it with vogue cover,
get drink for thousands of people,
right?
So when you find a drug and
it has to be smuggled around,
you get a premium on getting the
biggest possible kick into the smallest
possible space,
right?
This is why mild forms of
the drug disappear before
opiates were banned in the
United States.
Most popular way of consuming it was
something called Mrs Winslow sue things
Syrup,
which you would buy in the pharmacy,
right?
Very low level of opiates.
Most popular way of consuming cocoa based
products prior to the banning was Coca
Cola,
right?
It's called that for a reason.
Uh,
when the ban happens,
heroin becomes something from opiates.
Powder cocaine becomes
the only form of cocaine.
In fact,
when there's a huge crackdown on powder
cocaine in the 80s the iron law kicks in
even more and that's when
crack is invented because
you can get even more of a
hair into an even smaller possible space.
Right?
So I think he's important.
Understand if you want,
it is not good.
Most people who drink alcohol don't want
to drink vodka and they certainly don't
want drink absinthe most of the time.
Right.
Most people want a mild
form of their drug.
That's true.
Cannabis.
Of course,
there's some people who want
to get totally fucked up
either for fun or because
they have addiction problems.
Most people want a mild form of the drug
is not good that malforms or the drug
when they're not.
I don't think that's true.
It's definitely not true.
In California,
in California,
what happened was medical care cannabis
got passed and once medical cannabis got
passed,
there was a an emphasis on the strongest
possible stuff because people wanted
it.
I mean,
it was a direct result of people having
higher tolerances because marijuana was
so readily available and they,
if you have a high tolerance
and you smoke a lot of pot,
you want strong pot because
week pot doesn't do anything.
It's the number one complaint amongst
cannabis enthusiasts is someone having
week pops.
You've got a subculture of people
who are cannabis enthusiasts.
Who do you write?
There's a sub.
Just like there's a subculture of
people who want Volcker App south.
Right,
right.
But I don't think it's a matter.
It's not the same thing.
Like gender obviously is more potent
than whiskey or then beer rather.
It's easier to carry gen around.
You have to carry less of it.
With cannabis,
people are still buying the same quantity.
They're just getting more
fucked up because their
tolerances are so much higher.
They need a stronger and stronger THC.
So as you have a legal market,
you can have a variety of options.
What you have is what,
what we'll discover.
I think as time goes by,
because we know with alcohol is different.
People want cannabis
to do different things.
You're totally right.
There's some people who want
maximum THC maximally fucked up.
Some people where there's still a
market for for lower grade we'd,
I mean they have it listed
at all these dispensaries.
They have it listed,
you know,
20% 35% they have it listed.
So you can choose a more mild
marijuana if you like to,
but the gee people,
the people that do it every day,
of course they want
that really potent weed.
It's not like I would say they're more
like the people in Vegas who gamble a
professional gamblers versus the people
who go to Vegas for the weekend and just
want to play a real well.
There's definitely a concentrated market
of very dedicated users who want to get
maximally fucked up.
You're totally right now.
I think that's what pushed the Po.
I mean it's also in botanists and I'm
friends with a bunch of people who breed
and grow these various strains.
If you think about,
so professor David [inaudible] has
done really interesting work on this.
If I remember rightly,
there's 38 active components in cannabis,
right?
So cannabinoids,
so there's hundreds of cannabinoids.
I think the,
if I'm,
if from press and elsewhere,
he,
he'll gives this kind of
significant active components.
Maybe other people.
Yeah.
I think there's over a hundred,
uh,
canabinoids I think we
just discussed this,
right?
Right.
Then we,
uh,
so one of the things he Auggie's and I'm
happy to be corrected on the specific
number,
but one of the things he,
he Auggie's um,
is you've got it,
cause you're talking about schizophrenia
and psychosis.
I think it's important to understand
there is some evidence that very high
exposure to THC in a small
number of people can,
can lead to psychosis.
Right?
And that's even a small number of people
where you have a very widely used drug
is,
is that's really problematic.
Right?
But actually this was range the evidence.
So why do people who are prone to
psychosis or schizophrenia want cannabis?
Right?
Cause there is a lot of them who want it.
It's not the people,
hardly anyone wants to
have a psychotic episode.
It's actually so THC,
um,
uh,
correlates with,
with psychosis in some people.
But there's another component,
cannabis called CBD,
Cannabidiol,
which actually we know there's good
evidence soothes the psychosis and
schizophrenia,
right?
It's actually given us a treatment in
some places in distilled pill form.
So actually it's a slightly more complex
picture then cannabis causes psychosis,
right?
Very rich THC in some
people will cause psychosis.
That's a real problem.
There are things we
can do to prevent that.
And one of the good things about
legal market is you can regulate it.
So we can limit the amount
of THC that is available.
Just like we can limit,
you can't go and buy 70% proof alcohol,
but also what,
what,
what professor not has been
arguing is we need to be,
and they exist,
but they need to be
commercialized and promoted more,
um,
or promoting public health way
and not necessarily commercially,
um,
CBD rich cannabis will actually be
helpful to people with psychosis and
schizophrenia.
It's just a slightly
more complicated picture.
I know that you,
you,
you're not saying that it is,
you're not endorsing what the,
tell your kids got.
What's it called again?
I'm the guy who did your debate.
Um,
our experienced,
yeah,
I know you're not endorsing the kind
of simplistic view on either side,
but the,
the,
um,
I think it's slightly more,
slightly more complicated than that.
The other thing I think is really
worth saying though to people is,
there's one thing we will do agree on,
which is cannabis is
bad for young teenagers,
right?
It's after developing brains.
There's one person that
interview to really helped me to,
again,
to think about this guy
called Fred Martins,
who's in,
I went to go see him in Camden,
New Jersey,
and Fred was a co,
he's retired now,
but he was a cop.
I was really kind of right
when it reminded me of the
clinics were character and
dirty Harry.
He's not a liberal.
Right.
And he had this,
he wouldn't use a fancy word like this,
but he had an epiphany
about drug legalization.
One day he was at a car park in Wayne,
New Jersey in 1971 it was staking out
a dealer and he's in plain clothes
obviously.
And a kid comes up to him like an 11
year old or something and it goes,
hey,
Mr.
Um,
I'm not allowed to buy alcohol where you
go in to that liquor store and buy some
for me.
And frank goes,
no,
get outta here.
So the kid walks over to the drug dealer
and buy some drugs from him instead.
And Fred has this kind of realization,
which is,
oh,
he wouldn't put it this way,
but legalization puts a regulatory barrier
between kids and drugs that doesn't
currently exist.
Right?
This is why since they
legalized cannabis in Colorado,
there's been this,
don't overstate it.
It's not huge,
but there's been a significant
fall in teenage cannabis,
right?
Drug dealers don't check ID
licensed legal businesses.
Do they really care if they're there
because they've got something to lose?
Right.
So I think if sometimes it's used as
that kind of protect our kids argument is
used as a case for prohibition.
In fact,
if you want to protect your kids,
you should be putting a big premium on
getting these substances out of the hands
of armed criminal gangs and into the
hands of licensed legal businesses.
Yeah.
I don't think anybody's
going to argue that.
I mean I think that
anybody rational rather,
uh,
I think that makes a lot of sense.
I think that,
um,
the,
the number of people that
have schizophrenia is fairly,
it's fairly stable in terms of the
percentage of it across the board,
cannabis users or non cannabis users.
And so the argument against this idea
that cannabis causes a schizo frantic
breaks is that these people already have
schizophrenia and it just hasn't really
manifested itself in a,
in a tangible sense.
So this is one of the
things professor nuts says.
So there's this,
there is some evidence that cannabis
in a small number of people causes
psychosis as a study in Sweden that
showed this with schizophrenia,
it's much more contested.
So,
so psychosis versus schizophrenia.
What is the major distinction?
Yeah,
I have not researched this in depth,
but um,
psychosis involves,
um,
is that the different,
the different paranoia.
Schizophrenia is a subset of
mental illness is very specific,
has a significant genetic component,
although there can be
environmental triggers for it.
So it could possibly trigger both.
It could possibly trigger psychosis and
schizophrenia argument against the APP.
So professor.
So there is evidence with psychosis,
the argument when a stress,
it's a very small number of people,
but it Israel,
um,
uh,
and there are things we can do in
a legal market to counteract that,
that are much harder to
do in a prohibited market.
But with schizophrenia,
the argument against it,
and I've not looked into this
and a huge amount of detail,
so I don't want to,
this is not the same degree of confidence
I've been saying the other stuff,
but,
um,
professor not argues,
well,
we know that cannabis use has
massively increased in Britain,
for example,
I think something like 20 fold increase
since 1916 Britain and yet levels of
schizophrenia have remained the same.
If cannabis was causing schizophrenia,
you would expect it to
vary with cannabis use,
at least to some degree,
there'd be some relationship.
And that doesn't seem to be the case.
So again,
I,
that's what professor,
not,
who's the former chief scientific
advisor on drugs in Britain says,
I haven't looked into
that in great detail.
So He's basically right.
And all the things that I
have looked into that he says,
hmm,
mmm,
do they know what the mechanism would be
that would cause someone to consume THC
and have a psychotic break?
Have that,
does that have been examined?
I don't enough about it.
That would seem to be a big issue.
Right?
Like find out what it is that's causing
this trigger and whether or not this
exists in these people anyway,
and maybe a stressful situation
and a bad breakup losing their job.
Maybe one of those things could also,
it's true.
Well we know with all mental health,
all aspects of mental health
or mental health problems,
there were three kinds of calls,
right?
Those,
my bit lost connections,
which about depression,
anxieties,
a lot about this.
There are biological causes,
things like your jeans,
real brain changes,
things like the introduction of a drug.
There are psychological causes to how you
think about yourself and your place in
the world.
And then there's environmental causes.
Like,
you know,
how we live with each other,
things like loneliness,
that sort of thing.
Um,
and in all mental health
phenomena to some degree,
these three sets of courses player.
So let's think about even something very,
uh,
dementia.
Dementia as a very obviously
has a heavy biological driver,
right?
Dementia is a physical degeneration of
the brain or a disease like Alzheimer's.
Um,
but even with dementia,
which has this very
heavy biological driver,
we know there are big social
and psychological effects
that can mitigate it.
So if you're part of a strong community
and have lots of social connections,
if you have a positive self image,
if you speak other languages,
you're dementia will develop significantly
more slowly than if you don't have
any of these factors,
right?
So with things like psychosis,
there's a brilliant person
called Tanya Lurman,
Professor Daniel Lemon at Stanford
University who's done really interesting,
uh,
research and sandwich
and to in great detail,
but I interviewed her,
um,
who,
who shown.
So we know recovery from psychosis or
schizophrenia is much stronger in African
countries than it is in the United States.
Right?
And it's not a genetic thing because
Africans who come to the United States end
up having the American level of recovery,
not the African level of recovery.
And um,
again,
it's a while since I spoke [inaudible]
I don't want to overstate my confidence
about this,
but there are other people,
there are people I think including her,
who argue in part.
What's going on is in many,
not all.
Some places it's really brutal,
but in many parts of Africa,
you remain part of the community.
Even if you have these
mental health problems,
right?
They have much stronger
social connections.
It's a study that asks Americans,
how many close friends do you have
who you could turn to in a crisis?
And when they started doing it years ago,
the most common answer was five.
Today,
the most common answer is none,
right?
It's not the average,
but it's most common answer.
Half of all Americans asked,
how many people know you?
Well say nobody,
right?
It's a huge amount of evidence.
Loneliness is toxic for human beings.
Lonely people as guided
a to experiments on this.
Here in La,
lonely people exposed to the flu virus
and the cold virus and the colds are way
more likely to actually get
them the non lonely people.
Right.
Um,
it's just devastating for your physical
and mental health to be lonely.
There's other things going on.
So I think there's a whole range of
things that are going on with all mental
health problems.
I don't know how this relates
to cannabis and psychosis.
I don't want to,
I don't know.
But we know with psychosis,
yeah,
there's,
there's a big debate about this.
Immigrants are more
likely to have psychosis.
The nonimmigrant says there's a whole,
um,
lots of environmental factors playing out,
even in extreme mental health problems.
Like now I want to stress
they're not the only thing.
There are real biological aspects as well,
uh,
which are clearly very significant and
things like schizophrenia and play some
role in things like depression
for a lot of people.
But,
but yeah,
so that makes sense.
Yeah.
I mean,
sort of.
Yeah.
I mean,
obviously there's varying
biological factors,
but the cultural factors make sense.
The fact that these
people in Africa are not,
they're not expelled from the community,
so they have a sense of bond and
maybe it's more easy to recover.
And one of the things that you hear about,
part of the problem with mental illness
is that people with mental illness are
pushed away.
People don't want to deal with their
problem and it exacerbates whatever is
causing it in the first place.
What drugs have you used?
Just have to be slightly Kaplan.
My answer,
because I'm in an immigration
process a lot to me,
I got a prescription legal drugs,
so I used to drug illegally.
That is prescription drug is so
called Modafinil or provigil.
Why did you use it illegally?
It's pretty easy to get a prescription
for nine Britain register.
Explain to people who don't know.
Pro Provigil is a drug that was developed.
People with narcolepsy was
actually developed as a
a performance enhancer and they just
had to find a reason to use it the other
way round.
How interesting.
They had to find a reason to use it.
And the reason to use it was to say,
oh,
let's give it to people with narcolepsy.
Let's do that.
Let's check to see if that's true,
because that's how it's been explained
to me by actually by my doctor.
Oh,
that's really interesting.
I perfectly prepared to,
I don't know about that,
but sounds plausible to me that,
so I think for me,
do you use that a lot?
No.
So is it now,
so for me,
um,
I think I did have an addiction to that.
What had addiction to,
was working all the time.
I grew up in a
crazy and violent environment in many
ways and my way of where there's addiction
and other things and my way of coping in
that environment was to read and write
all the time to just not be present by
just working right in front of a small
child.
And as I got older,
um,
that was really my way
of being in the world,
right.
To work all the time.
Um,
and I think when I got into my,
like late twenties,
I can't remember,
I wrote an article about
Modafinil so it could,
I could find,
figure out when I started taking it.
But the,
cause I initially wrote a very
positive article about it.
Um,
I was at that point where the obsessive
and compulsive work wasn't working for
me.
Right.
It wasn't an like a lot of
people with addictive behavior.
I was doubling down on the thing
that wasn't working that well.
So for me,
Modafinil was,
or provigil I bought it on the Internet.
Um,
was a way I thought initially and make
it so I could work even more hours to be
even more right.
And initially when you start taking it,
a lot of people take it
before exams for example.
Um,
it does make you feel,
it's not a caffeine buzz.
It wasn't for me anyway,
it's just you feel like you can just,
yeah.
Have feeling when someone put it to me,
it wasn't a scientist,
it could be bullshit.
But,
um,
so we evolved to,
uh,
we had this thing called executive focus,
right.
I'm executive focus on now,
I'm really concentrating
on what I'm saying to you.
You the signals coming you right.
But obviously we can't be in a state
of executive focus all the time,
right?
But what Modafinil does is it,
it makes you much more in a state
of executive focus for longer.
And you can see why
people evolved to do that.
If you were,
and where we have all of
you being chased by a lion,
you're brain just switches off
all the other shit and he's like,
get the fuck away from the lion.
Right?
Right.
And my understanding is that
modafinil triggers that,
that state,
not a panicked state,
but uh,
executive focus date,
which is good for a while,
except there are two really
big downsides to that.
Firstly,
you don't sleep and if you don't sleep,
you were fucking crazy.
I'd never heard that there's an issue
with sleeping and modafinil or provigil.
In fact,
that's one of the positive aspects of it,
that you can sleep on it.
Oh,
well,
I mean,
it was designed for people who
find it hard to stay awake.
And that's not true.
Oh,
that's what I'm reading.
What are you reading that?
Uh,
the guy who discovered it,
Michael is Uva was a sleep study.
Yeah.
Neurophysiologist and was working on the
compound add dry or address funnel and
then they discovered then made modafinil,
which is a stronger version of that.
Mm.
So mine,
is there anything that says that
it was originally developed?
See anything like that?
Fucking doctor.
Yeah.
My experience was t two problems.
So firstly,
um,
I don't know how everyone says I haven't
done a huge amount of research on this
drug.
My experience was firstly not sleeping,
which is really bad for you over time.
And secondly actually if
you're in that focused mode,
so your,
your mind needs time wandering.
Sorry.
You mind needs time to wonder.
Right.
It needs time.
You know,
if I just leave here and
walk out there on the street,
my brain will just start wondering around
loads of things and then it will go
back into executive focus when I
do the next interview or whatever.
You need those periods when you're not
in exact focus when you're exactly,
well not even recovery.
That's where recovery is part of it.
That's when your brain
often has creative thoughts.
Right.
When you're wondering where your mind is
wondering when things will come to you
cause that a certain amount of your mind
is processing things even though you're
not conscious of it.
That's what I felt with
new vigil that it didn't,
new vigil or pro vigil,
they're very similar.
It didn't seem like there
was much creativity going
on that it was more of like
a grunt tool.
How long did you use it?
Portrait?
Um,
I mean I,
I would not use it regularly.
I would take it like
once a couple of weeks,
once a week or so like that.
Uh,
how long?
Um,
I think I did it for like a year,
a year or so,
and then I just stopped.
I haven't taken it in years.
Right,
right.
But I liked it.
What did you like
from,
um,
some guy was a bio hacker who was the
one who told me about it and he said it
was pretty easy to get
a prescription for it.
I've got a prescription for it.
And uh,
it just gave you like this pepped up
sense of a focus and awareness felt you
could get a lot done when you're on it,
but it didn't seem like it helped with
those wandering creative thoughts as you
were saying.
Yeah.
If I was ever going to do exams again,
which fortunate we'll never do in my life,
I,
I would use that.
But I think,
I think you're right.
And I think again,
thinking about that
about in relation to addiction,
I think often when you talk
about sing like work addiction,
right?
[inaudible] caused by partly
childhood trauma that I'd experienced.
There's been a real change in
how we think about that as well.
It relates back to what we're saying
right at the start about chemical hooks,
right?
So if you look at the debate about um,
non drug based addictions,
right?
If think about 20 years ago,
people start talking about sex
addiction guy called Stanton peal,
who I interviewed a lot first writes
about love addiction or smiling exactly.
Gambling addiction at the time.
Initially what people say,
well this is bullshit because they
believe the chemical hooks there of
addiction.
Right,
right.
So it just seems like,
well that's not,
I mean there's an episode
of cheers actually,
which I'm now we're be,
yeah,
you wouldn't do this,
but there's an episode where the whole
hilarious premise of the show is that
what's the Ted Danson,
Sam Malone,
Danson's character thinks he's a sex
addict and this is like a punch line all
the way through the show.
Right?
This was the attitude that ends with,
it goes through an meeting of sex and
love addicts anonymous and like there's
some women talking about how she
gets like has sex with every,
every Madden ends with him just putting
his arm around her and that's the end of
the,
the end of the show.
Right.
That wouldn't happen in a sitcom.
Now people,
people thought,
well it might,
but people,
people don't think the,
the very idea of sex addiction is
ridiculous in the way they did.
Right.
I don't think,
I think maybe they do.
Maybe,
but then I think that's because
there hasn't been a shift in gamble.
If you go to a meeting,
a gambler's anonymous
as I have with a friend,
not,
I don't have a gambling problem,
but just to support someone.
They are as addicted as anyone in the
next room down at narcotics anonymous.
No one,
a lot of,
not a lot of gambling addicts.
And did you feel that
they were as a dictator,
they're there,
they're straight up junkies and
they might as well be chasing crack.
He,
and that tells us something
really important because
you don't snore a roulette
wheel,
right?
You don't inject a an online poker,
If you can have a professor
not said this to me,
if you can have all of the addiction,
but none of the chemical hooks that tells
us about how we've overestimated the
role of calories,
addiction,
Chemical Hook,
there's a dopamine addiction.
Well absolutely everything you do
that you like gives you dopamine.
It haven't been hit.
So I think there's been this
attempt to integrate it by going,
oh well there's this pleasure in the
brain and but it's also a of self
destructive issue.
There's something about gambling,
there's a lot of self hate involved.
And,
and,
uh,
this,
this overwhelming feeling
of failure that a lot of,
uh,
gambling addicts hub because
they fail so often and they're,
they're always trying to chase the dragon.
They're always trying to make
up for all the past things.
They've gone wrong.
This big score with this big score,
are we going to settle it
out towards me about it?
Just think about what you're
saying in relation to him.
A guy called Peter Cohen,
he's a professor in the Netherlands who
actually didn't say this to me directly.
I read it.
Um,
he says we shouldn't call it addiction.
We should call it bonding.
Human beings have an innate
need to bond and connect.
Right?
And you're happy and healthy.
Your bond and connect with like the
people around you with meaningful work.
If you can't do that cause you're
isolated or traumatized or beaten down by
life,
we haven't been taught how to do that.
You will bond with something that
gives you some sense of relief.
Right now for some people
that might be porn,
for some people that might be gambling,
for some people might be cocaine,
alcohol,
whatever.
But it says,
if you,
if you only have one bond
that's given you any relief,
you will obsessively
returned to that bond.
Right.
And I don't think that's a total lie.
He,
and as he would say,
that's not a total explanation
for what's going on.
But I do think that is a useful way to
think about some of these behavioral
addictions.
Right?
So I,
someone I know very well,
um,
a relative of mine has a gambling
addiction and this is someone who has,
yeah.
No alternative form of joy
or pleasure in their life.
Right?
And
yeah,
gambling gives a moment
among lots of moments.
I've just such,
if you look at someone who's
playing online poker as I've done,
my,
my relative,
they're not happy or
it's not a look at it.
Someone watching a nice movie,
right?
It's,
you can see,
I don't mean,
I'm sorry.
I should be someone with an addiction
problem playing online poker.
Some people have,
most people don't have a problem,
right?
It's the,
it's the relief of just being absent from
your life for a moment or for however
long you play,
rather than,
um,
I went to this fellow's connections,
my book about depression.
I went to the first ever Internet
Rehab Center in the United States.
It's a weird places,
oppressive place such that
I liked the people there.
It's in Spokane and just
outside Spokane in Washington.
It's called restart,
restart Washington.
And I remember going there.
Really,
it was really interesting
to think about this.
Um,
I remember arriving,
it's a clearing in the woods,
right?
A big wooden place in the
clearing of the woods.
I remember absolutely
instinctively looking at my
phone and feeling really when
a minute I got out the car and fit of
really pissed off that I can check my
email.
I was like,
oh wait,
you're in the right place.
Right.
Um,
and it's an ancient cause.
They get all kinds of people
and restart Washington,
but they disproportionately get young men
who are obsessed with multiplayer role
play games.
Like,
then it would have been world of
Warcraft and how it'd be fortnight.
And speaking to these young men
have this realization,
talking to the woman who runs it.
It's amazing when called Dr Hillary cash.
He said to me,
you've got to ask.
I think it relates to what
you saying about gambling.
You got to ask what these young men are
getting out of this game because they're
getting something out of it.
Right?
And she argues that one of the things
that getting is the things they used to
get from the culture,
but no longer gap.
Like what,
what are filling?
They're good at something,
a feeling that other people see them,
that they're part of a tribe,
a feeling that they're moving around,
you know,
um,
kids spend very little time outdoors now.
Right?
I think there's also anticipation.
There's puzzles,
there's things where you're trying to
figure out whether or not something's
right or wrong and how to get it.
And if you do get it,
you get this positive
surge of you don't get,
I mean,
I think there's human reward systems that
are being mirrored there in gambling.
And what psychologists call,
call that feeling of mastery.
The masters,
when you feel you are good at something,
right?
It's an absolutely underlying
psychological need.
Everyone needs to feel
that good at something.
If you don't have a sense
of mastery in your life,
you will be depressed and anxious.
Right?
Or you're much more likely to
become depressed and anxious.
And I think again,
because it's very striking to me,
I've got teenage nephews,
I've got sons.
We actually don't ask
anything of young men.
Right?
Very rarely are they actually
asked to do very much.
They're not given responsibilities.
Right.
I think I look again,
I want to stress and most people
playing video games or not addicted,
it's perfectly good form a pleasure.
They're very addictive.
I mean,
they're not.
Most people playing them have a
healthy relationship with them.
And the same way that,
I don't know if that's true,
can maybe tell me about it.
A lot of people playing them
have a real problem with them.
They take up massive hours at a time.
It's a giant problem with young boys.
I mean the,
the thing is it's become an
actual avenue for career.
Now there's east sports careers where
these young guys are making millions of
dollars playing video games.
It's not like the old
days where you would say,
hey,
you're wasting your life.
Now it's basically almost
like practicing golf.
But we have a set up back here.
Well we play video games
against each other.
That's very addictive.
Don't you think it's addictive?
Sure.
Yeah,
so it's like basketball
when I was younger too,
I loved playing basketball,
couldn't get me to play in the rain.
The basketball has movement and exercise
attached to it so you get some positive
benefit from that addiction.
I was definitely addicted to Jujitsu.
I would even train when I was injured,
you know?
But what does that mean?
It means I enjoyed it more
than I enjoyed not doing it.
The difference between a lot of video
game addictions and particularly gambling
addictions is that they tend
to wreck people's lives.
You didn't,
when you had this period
of Jujitsu addiction,
did you,
did you cause they
distinction distinction there?
What are you doing it to avoid some kind
of pain in your life or were you doing
it because you just really deeply loved?
It's really fun.
Brio.
See chasing the thrill.
I mean,
I'm certain that was avoiding pain with
almost everything I've done in my life
in some way,
shape or form.
You know,
there's some of it where you're trying
to do something positive to mitigate the
pain or the frustration or the anger
or whatever it is that's bothering you.
But I don't,
you know,
I,
the video game thing was
a real addiction though.
It's like a compulsion.
And Alan was yours.
Yeah.
How did you,
how did you get out of the Jay?
I quit.
I just quit cold Turkey.
Stop playing.
I realized it was kind of messing up my
life and my career was just taking up
way too much time.
And I just,
I,
I came to a realization and I was like,
I gotta stop doing this.
I'm just playing way too much.
And so I just said,
the only way I,
I'm just too competitive.
I enjoyed it too much.
And so the only way to do it was
to stop playing it all together.
And we started playing it again
recently after more than Shit,
more than 15 years of
ever playing it at all,
you know,
and uh,
it's addictive,
but I'm so busy now,
I can't really fall into the grip of it.
I'm actually just enjoying
it for an hour here or there.
But
Oh,
interesting in itself,
isn't it?
That's a bit like the rap part principle.
It feels to me,
correct me if I'm wrong,
that light,
the more you have in your life,
that is meaningful,
that is good.
Am gives you pleasure
or a sense of mastery,
the less space they will be for
these objects of obsessions come in.
Right.
And I think that is a principle.
That's true.
This was the principle behind the
Portuguese drug decriminalization,
right?
If we give people good lives,
they will not want to
anesthetize themselves so much.
It was the Swiss principle and I think
we all see that in our lives to different
degrees.
I,
you know,
the happier I am,
the less I want to turn to,
uh,
you know,
the behaviors that I developed as a
child to avoid being present with like
violence and aggression.
Like
I don't think of like
writing as an addiction.
It's might be a compulsion if I
have a day when I didn't do it,
I feel terrible.
But something that is
positive and rewarding,
I don't think is an addiction.
Right?
Something that enriches
your life and is not,
it's a way of living life.
The most fulfilling way.
Theme session,
maybe a positive obsession,
compulsion,
obsession,
uh,
a way of being in the world,
right?
Like I don't,
it's like sometimes I
get people saying to me,
you know,
like,
oh,
am I addicted to sex in or
whatever and you want to say it.
I often say,
well,
does it give you pleasure?
Does it,
is it,
and is it a way of avoiding pain if it
gives you pleasure and it's not a way of
avoiding pain is not an addiction.
It's just a way,
a happy way of being in the world.
Right?
And that's the reality for,
and again,
I think it's really helps us because
partly what I'm arguing in loss in Las
collection and chasing scream is we need
to deeply reconceptualize how we think
about these forms of pain
like depression and addiction.
And this isn't some wacky basis,
the view of the World Health Organization,
these leading medical bodies
when it comes to depression,
the,
yeah,
sorry.
People that are journalists and
writers often like stimulants,
they often like Adderall.
Adderall is a big issue for,
for,
for journalists.
How much experience do you have with that?
Are All I'm to be used it,
it's supposed to be amazing.
You need it.
Never used it precisely
because I know I would love it,
right?
Like I would,
I've got a young relative
whose prescribed it and um,
that are the times when I've
been telling you he's a,
yeah,
he's offered,
tried to not spike me,
but like it's a joy to,
and this is for you,
but you know,
there's Adderall opens
up a whole other thing.
Right.
Which is this what you're
talking about again,
which is I'm not against people,
obviously not against people using
drugs in order to enhance their lives.
And I have,
before I came here,
I drank enough caffeine to kill
a whole fucking field of cows.
Right?
I assume viewers could probably tell,
um,
I,
I'm,
I limit my stimulant use because,
um,
because I know I can teach and
I can tell that I could easily,
a bit like we to beat the Modafinil
when I started using modafinil.
I got that sense.
I just used it everyday for three months.
Right.
Which was ludicrous thing to do.
But um,
I think in terms of stimulants,
there's a whole debate
that needs to be had.
Now,
I'm going to write about
this at some point,
but one in 10,
13 year old boys in this country
is being given a stimulant drug,
right?
In any given year,
For add or Adhd or,
I mean,
that is horrifying.
It's crazy.
Right?
30% of children in foster
care in the United States,
I've been given at least
one psychiatric drug.
These are not children
in the main who are,
you know,
have some biological insanity.
These are kids who've been fucking
abused and treated a bit smelly.
And what do we do?
We drug them to shut them up,
right?
Well,
it's also children have a lot of energy
and it's not easy to control them.
And so they decide that these children
have something wrong with them.
Do you know,
I went to this Amish
village Veloce connections,
but one thing that was really interesting,
there are these people who argued there
needs to be more research on this,
but Amish children don't get ADHD.
Right?
And this is big debate
what's going on there.
And so this one argument,
which is then obviously not
exposed to digital media,
which may,
and there's some evidence of just
speaking to professor Steven Lee here,
but people are getting a lot loads of
ADHD when I was in school and they're
exactly.
So,
So that's,
that's just because I
spoke to guy at Ucla,
Professor Stephen Asian.
There's some effect of digital media,
but it's not massive.
Right?
Right.
Um,
I think what's happening from the
very small amount of research you,
you're talking to the Amish is,
you know,
I'd say to them,
do you have kids who
don't want to sit still?
And they go,
yeah,
we'll let them go golf and go fishing.
Right?
The Amish don't want to make you
sit still for eight hours a day,
right?
There's nothing in their
society that I'm not idealizing.
The Amish has problems with getting a
child to sit still for eight hours a day,
just like trying to get a puppy to
sit still for eight hours a day.
Exactly.
That's exactly the right analogy.
What we do to our children.
We try to deaden them and discipline
them to cope and thrive in a dead end and
disciplines and inverted commerce economy.
Right?
If you,
the school system was designed in the
1870s to prepare people to work in
factories,
right?
If you're going to work
in a factory in the 1870s,
what do you need?
You need to learn to shut the fuck up,
not complain,
be passive.
Do what you're told.
Right?
It,
this is,
um,
I think it's a guy called Alfred cone.
I think it's him who says every school
has two curriculums or curricular over
the pluralists you've got
the official curriculum,
which is like geography,
history,
whatever.
And then you have the hidden curriculum,
which is the kind of person the
school is trying to make you into.
Right?
And what is the school system designed
to base designed to make people who are
passive,
who are,
uh,
obedient,
who sit still and shut
the fuck up right now.
That was never a good way to make humans,
right?
That was always wrong.
But it's particularly awful in the,
you know,
the culture we created.
But,
and this relates to one of the causes
of depression that I write about in Los
Connections,
which is,
you know,
it's really good.
I know it's the loads of the people
I know who are depressed and anxious.
Their depression and anxiety
focuses around their work.
We talked about this last time.
I was on a thing,
um,
but I was like,
okay,
people,
I know,
maybe they're unusual,
right?
So start to look at the evidence base.
Gallup did a really big study
of people in the U S and Europe.
See,
what do people feel about their work?
Right?
13% of people,
one,
3% like their work,
most of the time,
63% of what they called sleep working,
you know,
like it,
you don't hate it.
You kind of tolerate it.
And 24% of people fucking
hate and fear their jobs.
And so you think about that,
that means 87% of people don't like the
thing they're doing most of the time.
Now,
that can't be far off what the
figure was in the Soviet Union,
right?
That's a really extreme,
bigger.
Um,
and I'm like,
so I'm looking at this,
I'm thinking,
okay,
could this bear some relationship
to our mental health crisis,
right?
This thing that we don't like is
spreading over more and more of our day.
The average person I think
answers the first email,
I think it's 7:43 AM and
leaves work at 7:15 PM right?
W and I learned this in an amazing
Australian social scientists or went to
interview call professor Michael Marmot
who discovered the key factor that
causes depression at work,
right?
If you go to,
it's not the only one,
but key factor.
If you go to work tomorrow and you are
controlled so you have low or no control
over your work are much more likely
to become depressed and anxious.
I think it relates to what we've
been talking about all along.
People have psychological needs.
You need to feel you're good at something,
you need to build.
Your life has meaning.
If you're controlled all the time,
you can't feel that.
Right.
So when I first learned this,
I remember first time I went
to see professor [inaudible]
like misunderstanding
the implications of this cause
I thought he was saying wrongly,
I thought he'd be saying,
okay,
you've got this 13% of elite people at
the top like you have me who get to have
jobs we love and then you've got
everyone else's condemned to the shit.
Right.
I thought about my family.
My brother is an Uber driver.
My,
my dad was a bus driver,
my grandmother cleaned toilets.
I'm like,
wait,
are we saying they're just
condemned to these miserable lives?
And explained to me it's not the
work that makes you depressed,
right?
He's being controlled at work
and there are solutions to that.
There are changes we can make.
Right.
Um,
I went to interview this woman
called Meredith Keough in Baltimore.
It's been part of this
really interesting change.
And sometimes some people listening are
going to think I'm going to say they
should do this and they
don't think I can't do that.
And it's right.
This is an argument or something else.
So Meredith used to go to
bed every Sunday night,
just sick with anxiety,
right?
Uh,
she had an office job.
It wasn't the worst office job in
the world as she would tell Ya.
She wasn't being bullied
or harassed or anything,
but it was boring.
It was controlled.
Couldn't just stand the thought.
This was going to be the
next 40 years of her life.
So one day with her husband,
Josh Meredith did this quite bold thing.
Uh,
Josh,
her husband had been working in bike
stores since he was a kid in Baltimore,
teenager and you know that's
controlled work is insecure.
You don't even have rights really.
And one day Josh and his colleagues in
the bike store and they ask themselves,
what does our boss actually do?
They liked their boss.
He wasn't a bad person,
but they were like,
we seem to fix all the bikes and
he seems to make all the money.
This doesn't seem like
such a good deal to me.
Right.
So they decided they were going to set
up a bike store that works on different
principle,
right.
The place they work before
it was a corporation.
Most people listening to your
show work in corporations.
You know how it's a very
recent human invention.
You know how it works as an army.
The boss at the top is
like the little dictator.
You've got to obey him or leave,
right.
And sometimes he's a nice dictator
and sometimes he's Kim Jong Un,
but you know,
you don't have much say over that.
Right.
Josh and his colleagues decided to set
up a bank store that works on a different
principle.
It's not a corporation,
it's a democratic cooperative.
So they don't have a boss.
They run the business together,
they take decisions about it together.
They have a meeting once every
couple of weeks in practice.
They agree,
but you know,
sometimes they don't and then they vote,
they share the profits,
they share out the good
tasks and the shitty tasks.
Um,
and one thing that was
so interesting to me,
their businesses called
Baltimore bicycle work,
spending time with them totally
in line with professor moments.
Findings is,
you know,
giving them back control over their
work made the much less unhappy,
depressed,
and anxious.
Right?
And it's not like,
you know,
they quit their jobs fixing bikes and
went off to become Beyonce is backing
singers,
right?
They fix bikes before they fixed bikes.
Now differences.
Now they've got control over their work,
right?
Giving people back control over their
work is a really powerful antidepressant
that every corporation could be,
could be a democratic cooperative.
Right?
That's a big change in our society.
But it's,
you know,
we've all lived through
big changes in our society.
There's no reason,
by the way,
it would be better for the economy.
Uh,
study at Cornell University found
democratic workplaces grow on average four
times faster than non
democratic workplaces because
people are more committed.
They bringing more of their energy
and their life to it that the,
we've got to understand Chris,
back to why the addiction is so bad.
It's,
we can understand people who are
showing these signs of distress,
depression,
anxiety,
addiction,
that they're doing that
not because they're crazy.
There are some biological
factors that are not rational,
but mostly it's just actually we built a
society that's not good for them and we
should be listening to that and
respecting that and like the guy doctor in
Vietnam said to me,
listen to your nausea.
It will tell us what's wrong with you.
We should be listening to their nausea
and using it as a kind of fuel to change,
change the way we live in ways that will
make or won't just make people who are
depressed and anxious and addictive.
Better off everyone's life will be better
off if they control their work more.
If you go through some of the
other big solutions to depression,
anxiety that I wrote about in,
in Las connections.
Now lost connections is
your most recent book.
Yeah.
That's the one about depression.
Is that Audi?
Yeah.
They're both available.
Now lost connections.
How did the two of them tie together?
So I wrote chasing the scream because
of this addiction in my family.
And I go on this big journey all over
the world to understand the drug war.
And I set a line in my,
I did a Ted talk about it called a,
everything you think you know
about addiction is wrong.
And I said a line in that,
which is the opposite of
addiction is connection.
I said earlier in our conversation
based on rat park,
right.
And lots of people started saying to me,
well,
are you just saying it's social isolation,
right?
Like loneliness.
And I very clearly in my moment,
no,
I don't think that's
the lesson of rat park.
Right?
I don't think that's just
what's going on in rat park.
It's,
they don't have anything
that makes life meaningful.
Now Rats obviously much more,
much less complex than ours.
Right.
So I started thinking,
well,
what,
what is actually missing
for people who are addicted,
depressed,
anxious,
what is driving this crisis?
So I think that question
that people kept asking me,
I could see the Portugal and Switzerland
had dealt with some problems of
disconnection,
but you weren't quite rightly
to think more question,
which,
what did Switzerland deal with?
Right.
That I couldn't quite,
I didn't quite ask cause it didn't quite
understand when I was in Switzerland.
So I ended up again going on this big
journey all over the world from a crazy
mixture of places like an Amish village
in Indiana because the Amish have low
levels of depression to a lab in
Baltimore where they're giving people suck
Adele links to your city in Brazil that
banned advertising to see if that would
make them feel better.
Did it?
Which bear?
Banning advertising.
Yeah.
So that's not been properly
scientifically studied,
but there is a science that tells
us it should explain what that is.
So this is,
everyone knows that junk food is taken
over our diets and made us physically
sick,
right?
But there's this really
interesting evidence,
the kind of junk values of taken over
our minds and made us mentally sick.
So to thousands of years,
philosophers have said,
if you think life is about money and
status and how you look to other people in
a kind of showing off way,
you're going to feel like shit,
right?
It's not an exact quote from Confucius,
but that is the gist of what he said,
right?
But weirdly,
nobody had ever scientifically
investigated this until an incredible guy.
I got to know cut professor
Tim [inaudible] who's at
Knox College in Illinois,
um,
and Professor Cassa,
uh,
made some really important
breakthroughs in this.
So
there's two ways everyone listening to
your show has two kinds of motivation in
their life,
right?
We're all a mixture of both.
So imagine if you played the piano in
the morning cause you love playing the
piano.
It gives you joy,
right?
That would be what's called an
intrinsic reason to play the piano,
right?
You're not doing it to
get anything out of it.
That's just,
that's the thing you love.
Right?
It sounds like Jujitsu was like that
view writing is like that for me.
Everyone will have something in their
life that just gives them joy as they do
it.
Right.
Can narrow imagine you played the piano,
not,
I dunno not because you love it,
but because your parents are
massively pressuring you.
It's their dream for you or in a dive
bar that you can't stand to pay the rent
or cuts impress a woman.
Right.
That would be what's called an
extrinsic reasons to play the piano.
Right?
You're not it cause that thing gives
you joy.
You're doing it to get
something further down the line.
Right now obviously we're
all a mixture of both,
but professor castle showed a
couple of really interesting things.
Firstly,
the more you are driven
by extrinsic values,
the more your intrinsic
values are starved,
the more likely you are to
become depressed and anxious,
but quite significant amount.
He also showed as a culture,
as a society,
we have become much more
driven by these junk values.
Right?
We've become much more driven by pick
about how Instagram makes you feel.
Sure.
Right?
We've become much more driven by
this hollow external sense of it.
Think about something as simple as,
well,
a while ago,
uh,
I was the Elton John's last
night in Caesar's palace,
right?
Amazing thing to be at.
And about half the fucking room is,
is filming it on that
isn't even looking out.
And John,
they're just watching
it through their phone.
Now,
that's a small example,
but you can see what they're doing
in order to display their life,
to invite envy from other people.
They are not living their life.
No one wants to watch
your shitty video about.
And John,
there's a hundred thousands of,
uh,
of videos about,
and John,
they are much better than yours,
right?
Why are you doing that?
You're never going to watch it either.
You're doing it to say to other people,
envy me,
right?
It doesn't make you feel good in that
room actually makes you feel worse.
You're not enjoying the experience and
it makes them feel like shit because
you're trying to invite
envy and your friends.
That's a small example of a much wider
thing of the kind of junk values of
technologies.
So the reason that relates to what
you're asking about Brazil is professor
castle are shown those two
sets of solutions to these
junk values taken over our
minds.
One is,
it's like fucking air pollution,
you know,
get the messaging out of your head.
More 18 month old children know
what the Mcdonald's m means,
the know their own survey,
their own last name,
right?
Um,
from the moment it's professor [inaudible]
put it to me from the moment we're
born,
we're immersed in a machine that is
designed to get us to neglect what is
important about life,
right?
None of your listeners will lie on their
death beds and think about all the shit
they bought and all the
likes they got an Instagram.
They'll think about moments
and meaning and connection.
That's like a banal,
obvious thing,
but we're constantly pushed
to not think in those terms,
to think about,
show it off by spend,
right?
These junk values have
taken over our minds.
So part of the solution is just fucking
get rid of most of this advertising,
get rid of most of this,
you know,
very tightly regulated.
But in doing so,
you limit commerce,
you're limiting people's
ability to sell things.
You're,
you're changing the,
the current market that a lot of
people don't have any problem with.
I know this is a heresy
in the United States,
but I limits in commercial
speech is fine by me.
Yeah,
I've,
I think it's fascinating.
I think it's a fascinating
discussion but it is in the,
in a sense it's limiting
free speech as well.
I mean,
and we have a real problem with that.
The problem with it is that as soon as
you start to put any regulations at all
and you know,
he say,
Oh,
you shouldn't be allowed to
advertising to advertise,
even if it's advertising.
Honestly about a great
product that people were,
we'll have real issues with that.
We already have advertising regulation.
You can't eat,
you can't pop an advert saying
I've found the cure for cancer.
Right.
That's what I'm saying.
So this is still,
I would argue this as a tightening.
So,
for example,
in London there was a big controversy,
um,
a couple of years back.
Any billboards.
Exactly.
So it was this,
it was a billboard of a impossibly hot
women and impossibly hot man and the
billboards had something like,
are you beach body ready?
The clear implication being,
if you don't look like these people who
you'll never fucking look like you're
not ready to go to the beach.
And the mayor of London
City can just said this,
you can't do this.
Right.
You can still advertise your bodybuilding.
That's so silly.
I mean,
this is a,
it's not an unobtainable ideal.
You're looking at two examples of it,
but hey,
they're real human beings.
Yeah.
But that's like,
I mean,
I know when I started listening,
I mean I'm not saying that
you have to be that way,
but if you do want to look like
that man and have that body,
it is a possible goal.
Yeah.
I mean it's not possible for
the vast majority of people,
right?
Like if they don't have
the time or the effort,
it's not,
but very many people have
radically changed their body.
I'm not saying,
not saying you should do it,
this is a possible thing to do.
And if you're trying to sell fitness,
wouldn't you sell an example of
someone who's really good at it?
Like if you're trying to
sell a business course,
wouldn't you show a guy with
a giant house and a Ferrari?
Like this is a guy who has
done really well at business,
look at his penthouse apartment
overlooking Manhattan.
You wouldn't show,
you wouldn't say,
well that's an impossible goal.
I'm going to show you a person in a middle
class suburb because this is as good
as you're ever going to get.
I think that's a fair point.
I think it's two things going on,
isn't there?
There's
the freedom of people to
market what they want to do.
Uh,
and there's,
um,
it's a nanny state issue that people
have a problem with you by saying that
these are impossible
to achieve body goals.
We already have regulation at these things
and people don't call that and nanny
state thing.
I think just this idea have regulation,
these things,
but that,
that is not,
I mean this,
I don't think this is a good example.
What's a better example?
So professor Cassa said there's two
sets of solutions to these junk valley's
problems.
There's,
um,
get the contaminants out of
the atmosphere sort of thing,
which he says is actually a weaker one
than the second set of solution says.
So how do we stop people
being pumped full of bullshit,
junk values,
right?
Educate them on what is happening
to them and make it less appealing.
Well,
this is the second part and you've gotten
to what I think was the most important
part of the research.
Professor Cassa did see,
he was working with a guy called Nathan
Dungan and Nathan is a hearing to be,
Nathan is a
financial advisor in Minneapolis.
And his job was to work with,
uh,
adults who are having trouble budgeting
and explain budgeting to them and help
them do it right.
And it gets a cool from a school,
it was kind of middle class
school wasn't super rich or poor.
It was a middle class.
Uh,
whether they're having a problem
that the kids at this school,
we're becoming obsessed with getting like
the latest Nike sneakers or the latest
iPhone or whatever it was.
And if their parents couldn't afford it,
the kids were really freaking out.
Right?
So they cite to
Nathan,
would you come in and just
explain budgeting to these kids?
Right?
So,
and I think Isaiah and he tries to
explain budgeting and quickly realize is
these kids don't give
a shit about budgetary,
right?
There's something else going on here.
They are so obsessed with
getting these things.
So with Professor Cassa,
he designs this program that led
to really interesting breakthrough.
It's saying people can try at home,
right?
You don't have to do it in this context.
So they'd got,
and you can do it just as adults,
but they did it with uh,
parents and the teenagers,
right?
They come in,
it was once every couple
of weeks for think,
four months and a fast.
They just say the first meeting they had,
they just said,
write a list of everything
you have got to have.
They didn't define that.
Right.
And people of course say like a home,
a car,
whatever.
But quite quickly people
would say Nike sneakers,
the parents would name
expensive things and they got,
okay,
tell me how you would feel if
you got these Nike sneakers.
Right.
And very rarely I only,
any of them were like basketball players,
so it was like,
I need the jump or whatever,
if that's the right phrase.
Um,
it was very low for ob.
Almost immediately it's,
I'd be accepted by the group.
People would envy me.
Right?
These days,
insights are just beneath
the surface where they go,
who put the idea in your head,
where did you get that idea?
And of course everyone thinks
they're smarter than the ad,
but giving people the ability just
to see how hollow those junk values,
where that was the first part,
second part was much more interesting
and took longer than I would have in
future sessions.
They'd say,
well,
okay,
given that not actually
made you feel better,
what are moments in your life
when you have felt satisfied,
happy in a flow state?
What are things that are meaningful
to you or people you know,
a whole range of things.
Playing sports or play music or reading,
whatever it was,
right.
And he said,
okay,
how could we build more of that into
your life and less of these junk values?
How could you do more of this
every week and just meeting?
We don't have these conversations
in our culture very often.
Just meeting once every couple of
weeks and checking in with HR and go,
actually,
I managed to play guitar
for an hour every day.
I managed on Saturday to take my
kids to the beach and we went,
or whatever.
It's going to stifle materialism.
What it led to,
sepsis is monitored by Professor Cassar.
It led to a significant shifts
in people's values that they,
they,
they had a significant decrease in junk
ponies and a significant increase in,
in a more meaningful intrinsic values.
And we know that that correlates with
lower depression and anxiety over time.
The weird thing is I sometimes
feel like with all my,
we both my books chasing,
screaming,
lost connection.
So I sometimes feel like I'm giving
people permission to know the thing they
already know,
right?
Like had this a completely bizarre
experience when the book first came out,
why was being lost connections
that depression one where
I was being interviewed
by some American inns of your heart.
My heart was,
and um,
I talk about how loneliness
causes depression,
right?
And the interviewer goes saying like,
well,
this is a very controversial theory.
I'm kind of sitting there and I thought,
how did we get to the point?
We're pointing out the most
fucking obvious thing you
can imagine that if you're
really lonely,
are much more likely to become
dollar loans as controversial at all.
Think that person's silly.
I think the reason it's controversial
is because these biological stories,
which have some truth in them,
have dominated how when I was a teenager,
I went to,
it's only thought of as being exactly
when I went to my doctor when I was a
teenager and I was really depressed and
I said I had this feeling like pain was
leaking out of me and
I couldn't control it.
My doctor told me,
and entirely biological teacher said,
there's just a problem with your brain
here and all you need to do is drug
yourself.
Right?
Right.
And I drug myself and I've got some
relief from the chemical antidepressants,
but it did not solve my depression.
And one of the reasons I wrote lost
connections is cause after 13 years of
taking the maximum possible dose,
I was like,
well,
what's going wrong here?
There's something missing in this
picture cause I still feel depressed.
And every year that I've been alive,
I'm 40 depression and anxiety have
increased in the United States,
in Britain,
and across the Western world.
There's something missing in this picture.
And I think the reason
why that's controversial,
it seemed controversial that women,
even though to you and me,
it's crazy to think it's controversial,
is because these biological stories
which have some basis in reality,
have become the whole of the
picture for a lot of people.
Right.
I had a completely
bizarre experience where,
you know Peter Taylor,
have you had him on your show?
No,
but I know him.
Yes.
A pizza tell people who don't know is the
founder of paypal gazillionaire right.
Back to the Trump campaign.
I got an invitation from Peter Teal
just before it was after Trump had been
elected,
but before he'd been inaugurated
his people to go to a,
they were organizing a conference for
APP developers who are trying to develop
apps to deal with depression,
anxiety and addiction.
And I'm a bit like,
I don't think apps are
really the solution,
but I wanted an excuse to
go to San Francisco anyway,
so I go,
so day long conference,
I didn't hit every speech,
but some really great scientists,
people like Thomas and saw who was the
former head of the National Institute of
Health,
who's hugely armor man.
And I'm sitting there and I'm like,
all they're doing is looking
at pictures of brain scans.
Right.
If all you knew about depression and
anxiety was this conference and addiction,
you would literally think they were just
things that happen inside the brain.
Yes.
And I'm like the last person up,
I don't think this was designed this way.
Maybe they did.
I'm saying that I'm thinking,
what do I say to these people?
And I thought,
you know,
it's like I was trying to get metaphors.
You could have a conference about obesity
that just looked at scans of people's
stomachs,
right?
It wouldn't be untrue.
It wouldn't be bad science,
but had missed the whole
fucking reason why they're fat.
Right,
right.
But you could,
you could tell the plot of Romeo and
Juliet using like Newtonian physics.
You could draw a diagram.
Romeo moves this way,
Juliet,
you won't understand a re a damn
thing about why anyone does anything.
Right?
It was such a deep misunderstanding
or not misunderstanding such a partial
truth.
Right?
And I said to them,
so we were in San Francisco where
we're really near the tenderloin,
which helps the people knows a place,
a lot of chaotic straight addiction.
It's like,
let's not discuss this.
Let's all just walk
over to the tenderloin,
sit with the first person
with an addiction problem.
We meet,
listened to their life story for half an
hour and come back and tell me the main
problem here is,
is a malfunction of the Amygdala.
It's a bizarre misunderstand that.
Is there something going
on with making lists?
Yes.
Is it important to
understand that science,
of course,
right?
I'm strongly in favor of brain science.
I'm in favor of the science
of understanding the stomach.
It's a bizarre reduction of what human
beings are to think that these are the
main drivers of these crises.
Right.
It's ridiculous.
Yeah.
Sorry,
I agree.
And we have to wrap this up.
Were were already after
I really drove the truck.
Can I just say very quickly that anyone
who wants any more in from a publishers
fucking whip me if I don't say this,
uh,
anybody wants any more information about
either of my books chasing the scream
is WWB dot chasing the scream.com you can
listen to audio of loads of the people
we've talked about and take a quiz to
see how much you know about addiction and
loss connections is
www.thelosconnections.com and
there are audiobooks are both
those books as well that
you can get on those sites.
Beautiful.
Thank you very much.
Cheers.
Thanks.
Hurray.